the democrats have introduced a bill
that would require proof of vaccination
a negative test or proof of recovery for
domestic flights this is already
alongside the 3.5 trillion spending bill
which has vax mandate enforcement in it
and i'll tell you this i don't see
republicans doing anything to stop it so
it seems very likely and perhaps a bit i
don't want to say pessimistic maybe it's
just realistic
that this is what's going to happen
and i i'm willing to bet by the time
2022 comes around maybe the republicans
come in and they win the house
we are we are already going to have
these laws on the books or something to
this effect it's going to be handed down
by edict
and it's going to further erode this
country there's some polling data we got
we'll get into in the show talking about
how basically
both uh democrat voters and republican
voters want the other to secede from the
union or basically just
peaceful divorce this country and so uh
we'll be able to talk a bit about that
uh we're going to talk about new
hampshire
the independence movement as i guess
some people prefer to call it but
secession and we're being joined by
jeremy kaufman founder and ceo of
library and board member of the free
state project it's great to be here with
you tim uh you wanna just quickly
introduce yourself yeah sure so the free
state project is the most successful
libertarian movement in the world
uh it's the it's the best attempt it's
the best chance that we have to actually
achieve liberty in our lifetime and i'm
going to talk to you about why that's
possible and then i'm also a founder of
the technology that i think is the next
generation to the sort of web 2.0 world
and it fixes a lot of the messed up
stuff that's been happening with big
tech
and that's a company called library lbry
although that's a decentralized open
source technology the easiest way to use
it is odyssey.com and you're on there as
well tim although you're not on there
live so this is youtube only right now
but all of your content is available on
odyssey.com and it's used by it was used
by more than 40 million people last
month so it's growing very fast wow big
yeah well we got to talk about
censorship too because youtube uh
censored ron paul and they said oops we
didn't mean to do that and he's now
doing exclusives on odyssey oh there you
go so um and they they also announced
they're banning any
anti-vex content so they banned a bunch
of people mentions of the person's name
it's crazy stuff yeah so we'll get into
all that stuff thanks for coming and we
definitely talk about new hampshire we
got ian odyssey is fantastic we're
looking at what the fetiverse buildout
that we're doing with this metaverse is
using odyssey as one of or library
technology is part of like a possible
server to host your content for your own
so you can kind of have access and
control your own
stuff oh yeah i mean it's the future and
the thing is like a lot of these other
ones like they are alternative
alternatives like they're literally
trying to clone we're not trying to
clone we've built something that's
better than what comes before it's
genuinely different it's all open source
it's all decentralized it has the
properties of bitcoin
where you own your following you own
your channel we've handcuffed ourselves
it's not possible for things to play out
the same way that they've played out on
the web 2.0 big tech world and the other
side of the equation is i feel like a
monkey in a cage and they're
experimenting on me and if i start
screaming and banging on the glass
they're going to ask me to step aside
and step out of public view so i'm going
to stay calm but i do feel like that
just put on a record
chicken and chicken coop yep i think we
should all stay calm tonight but i'm
really excited about tonight's
conversation because the new hampshire
thing is big news and seeing how many
people are in favor of the other side
seceding is kind of refreshing actually
so
but before we get started my friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
because we're gonna have a members only
segment up around 11 or so p.m but it's
not just about that it's about our
massive library of members only segments
you can search someone's name find the
all of the podcasts we've done them or
just go through the huge list going back
this entire year basically of all of
these bonus segments just getting better
and better as we go along and as a
member you support our fierce and
independent journalists like cassandra
fairbanks for instance who wrote about
senator feinstein's bill so go to
timcast be a member but don't forget to
like this video subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you really do like it give us a good
review if you're on a podcast or
whatever let's read this first story
from timcast.com
senator feinstein introduces bill to
require proof of vaccine negative test
or documentation of recovery for
domestic flights
the u.s air travel public safety act
would order the department of health and
human services and the federal aviation
administration to develop national
vaccination verification standards and
procedures the text of the act says that
it is necessary to reduce passenger crew
member and airport personnel risk of
exposure to covet 19. decrease the risk
of transmission of kovind 19 on board
aircraft in the united states uh and to
united states destination communities
through air travel
and protect children and other
vulnerable individuals by preventing
further spread of covenant in the u.s
under the bill a passenger would have to
provide the air carrier with
documentation demonstrating they are
fully vaccinated provide proof of
negative pre-departure or alternatively
written or electronic documentation of
recovery from covet 19 after previous
infection all right well that last part
at least i can give some respect to but
across the board i just don't have much
respect for this at all i think it
doesn't go far enough let's put it let's
put a scale like there when you check in
just check people's bmi if it's too high
you can't get on the plane i mean it's
about saving lives yeah actually you're
right that's a great point so there's
actually an issue with overweight people
on airplanes because when an individual
comes on a plane they actually there's a
there's a load manifest i used to i used
to work with these and you write down
average weight of cargo
depending on how many people are in the
plane and how much cargo how much
luggage in the plane the pilot has to
behave differently and move people
sometimes there were issues where there
was like very little uh luggage and
they're like okay that's gonna displace
the weight and put all the weight in the
front so they'd actually ask people to
move to even out that weight things like
that so yes people would complain
because they'd be like sir you're
overweight you have to occupy two seats
because we can't have the displacement
on the plane this way people didn't like
it
so what are they allowed to like if
someone has the flu can they not fly you
can fly sick you always have to be able
to it's kind of a dick move but i guess
some people you know are in a bind and
they can kick you off the plane for any
reason they're playing a private company
well they're not i mean that's what
we're seeing is they're not right i mean
if there's you know there's an example
of companies that aren't really private
companies it's airlines right they're
not the fact that the government can do
this is is an example of how they're not
remotely private companies if we had
private flight think about how awesome
it would be it'd be like and not that
megabus is like the most awesome
experience
it would be way closer to megabus
there'd be you know tens of thousands of
airports you'd fly out you'd drive out
to the middle of nowhere you'd get on
the plane 20 minutes after you got there
you wouldn't have to show id to anyone
there'd be all kinds of flights it would
be way more decentralized some random
pilot can you know rent a plane and fly
you places that's what a free market in
an air flight would look like we don't
have anything that remotely looks like a
free market you'd also be standing up
so they've actually experimented with
this yeah they're seats where you're
slightly sitting down they're like
straight up and they have a little like
hump on it where you can lean against
but you stand the whole time and they're
like we can get way more people on the
planes if we do this well i mean give
you know what like that can feel awkward
and understand but just give people
choices that's the point like if people
want to fly on a flight where everyone
is vaccinated let the market provide
that service if people don't give a [ __ ]
let the market provide that service when
the government is stepping in and saying
this is the way that planes have to run
that's not a choice that's the
government coming in the gun in the room
and saying you have to operate your
airlines you could do a roller coaster
flight as long as it's safe where every
so often the plane just drops a little
bit and then keeps going and drops as
long as it's safe and then you get the
roller coaster feel on your flight you
know perfect that'd be fun yeah if
people
why don't they do vacs and novak's
flights sure but it's public health this
is the thing we don't want to spread
travel is not should not be a privatized
in my opinion the roads the railroads
the planes should not be privatized
because someone can be like no you can't
travel because i don't like you i don't
like what your dad said to me 20 years
ago you're never allowed and then he's
like all his friends that own all the
other companies like yeah okay him and
his family forever that's the problem of
monopolization yeah which is maybe an
argument for rhodes but i don't think
it's an argument against planes because
planes it's so easy there's so much
space we're not running out of space
there's no monopoly on it there can be
there's no reason there shouldn't be a
hundred thousand
possible ways that you could fly you
know like think about how many people
are uber drive like flying would look
like uber much closer to uber not
necessarily where you're getting on your
plane in 10 minutes but it would look
much closer to that when you have this
vast variety of providers it's heavily
centralized in a small number of
companies because the federal government
made it work that way well they actually
are doing like uber for planes there's
companies where it's a private plane and
then you can you you basically say
here's where i'm going to this place the
faa shut some of these down by the way
oh wow yeah it's a it's a story to check
out there were some successful companies
doing this cfa faa came in and said
that's illegal wow yeah sounds right
wow that's the government again i guess
they think of planes as weapons because
they're they're so big and move so fast
they can cause destruction if they ram
into stuff so they're treating them kind
of like dangerous weapons you're gonna
what this basically means what they're
doing is all putting pressure on anyone
who opposes their agenda because you
know for the most part
a lot of most people are like oh the
vaccine's fine i guess but it's really a
decision between you and your doctor
that's what they're eliminating they're
taking your private choice out of the
equation and they're doing it in a way
that most like most people are probably
fine with and what i mean by that is
most people are like i get it vaccines
are fine
they see the data they say the news
there's an argument some people don't
like it but for the most part they're
like well you know it's
i get it right there's there's a
pandemic there's a crisis you want to
get a vaccine fine
the problem is they always use issues
like this to erode your rights they're
never going to come out and and demand
you do something ridiculous like you can
no longer have shoes and people would be
like what you can't do that no they do
something where they're like in this one
instance where it seems reasonable
you'll agree with us and then once you
give us the ability we'll do it for
everything so this this is going to turn
into a negative test but that's going to
turn into a negative test for everything
then it's going to be like you can't
travel if you're sick in any way
that's insane 15 days to slow the spread
just because we don't want to overload
the hospitals but we know it's going to
be here 15 days is all we need they want
to stop people from flying it's gone so
haywire look look aoc said they wanted
to stop people from flying that was part
of the green new deal yeah and there and
it seems like i'll tell you this they're
exploiting a crisis in every way
possible
to stop people from using look the
market's collapsing right we've got
economic crisis money being printed like
crazy people are fleeing cities shipping
containers all jammed up in in
california unable to come in they don't
want you buying stuff they don't want
you making stuff they don't want you
burning fuels they don't want you flying
on planes they don't want you driving
and so you got all these people in the
cities locked in their little cubicle
cubicle apartments losing their minds
well i think i think one aspect of this
is like politics is about tribal
dominance and the best way to dominate
someone else is when you can say this is
actually for the good of everyone and
that's why this situation has reached
this kind of fondness democrats want to
dominate republicans republicans want to
dominate democrats and this gives the
democrats a chance to dominate the
others in this way that is ostensibly
pro-social but it's really about
punishing people that they don't like
and i will i'll say this is also why the
free state movement is so important is
because libertarians need their own try
and it's not working nationally
libertarians need their own tribe as
well but right now a lot of this is it's
about tribal dominance and the fact that
it's about public health i think that's
pretend
well it's the the problem with
libertarianism is that people are
individualist
collectivists naturally have people who
will get behind them and say just tell
me what to do and i'm down whereas
libertarians are mostly like don't you
tell me what to do so have you found
like decentralized methods to unify
individuals
well the free state movement is pretty
decentralized so i'll i i'll give it
like a little bit of legalese here the
free state project which is the
organization that i'm representing all
we are is the marketing department we
don't engage politically all we do is
try to talk about how awesome new
hampshire is for libertarians the free
state project is 1 100th of what the
free state movement represents so i'm
like blm inc and then you've got the
free state movement right like if when
someone puts that blm sign and decides
to hold a rally they didn't consort with
blm inc they just did it on their own
and so most of what happens in new
hampshire is bottom up it's
decentralized is there fighting between
some of the libertarians of course there
is you can't get three libertarians in a
room without them you know fighting each
other um but i think it's by far the
most successful libertarian movement out
there and the nature of it is it selects
for people that want to win it doesn't
select for people who want to be you
know popular online or or want to go
into their you know dc crowd and and be
friendly with people that are their
enemies or that want to dominate them
it's a it selects for people who want to
actually achieve who actually want to
win and i don't think you're going to
find a movement that's much more
effective have you experimented with
like decentralized voting um for
localized voting like on apps and things
like that and finance with tokens and
things like that yeah i mean i love that
stuff of course to actually you'd have
to actually change new hampshire laws to
get that
one thing that does exist in new
hampshire because there's like seriously
like 100 different organizations that
play these kinds of bottom-up roles and
i'll give you an example of one that's
related to that there's a group called
liberty ballot and for people like i
hate i hate voting i think voting stop i
don't want to vote honestly like i would
i like the idea my ideal society is uh
is that of restaurants you know i have
no say on what's on the menu but i have
the choice of where i want to eat
competitive dictatorship
but i want to support free staters so i
vote when i'm in new hampshire i don't
pay attention to politicians i go on to
a website called liberty ballot it's run
by free staters free staters take the do
the job of parsing all the candidates
and saying these are the liberty ones
and i go in and i just check the box for
who they tell me to vote for and so
there's like
so many institutions and organizations
like this that are filling all these
roles that make the movement successful
that sounds crazy to me
like not knowing who you're voting for
well i trust the people who researched
it you can't i mean like it's it's no
different than any other consumer
decision like i don't know everything
about the [ __ ] you know i trust reviews
i trust things that i trust like people
trust you right you say something on
your show they trust you they know that
you're authentic and real and honest and
they trust what you say so and you know
so someone if your friend says hey this
guy's a really good guy you know vote
for him you trust me
that's usually because i'm like you guys
got to make sure you fact check this one
and do your own research you shouldn't
just blindly follow and and they'd say
the same thing and if they get it wrong
there are people who will criticize them
in forums and stuff like that it's not a
process without feedback but like i
don't want to pay attention to politics
right that's not i'm that's not my thing
i think politics is mostly dumb um i
mean i want to win so i have to engage
in it right but i don't really like
politics and so if someone else is will
that i trust is willing to do that
research and identify the candidates
that share my values you know why not
outsource it why not freeride peer
review is very powerful for um for like
anonymous social media if you want to be
anonymous online but you have enough
peers that can verify that based on what
your account's doing that that is ian
crossland then you can kind of trust
that it's me without knowing who i am
yeah yeah that's what identity is
identity is all statements that other
people make right like my id is the new
hampshire government saying that i'm
jeremy kaufman let's make the case for a
free state project in pro probably maybe
in a way you wouldn't be your first
go-to let me pull this story
this is from cnn the workers who keep
global supply chains moving are warning
of a system collapse
seafarers truck drivers airline workers
have endured quarantines travel
restrictions and complex covenanting
vaccination and testing requirements to
keep stretched supply chains moving
during the pandemic in an open letter
wednesday to heads of state attending
the united nations general assembly the
international chamber of shipping and
other industry groups warned of a global
transport system collapse if governments
do not restore freedom of movement to
transport workers and give them priority
to receive vaccines recognized by the
world health organization
we got trucker shortages here we got him
in the uk
the idea that you
will be able to just float in this
system and things are going to go like
normal like you can walk to the grocery
store and there your strawberries is is
a joke it's not true people need to
start being responsible for themselves
because they are telling us the system
is collapsing but i got one more for you
from timcast.com 82 of americans are
scared that supply chain issues will
ruin their life plans oh all right then
82 percent of people already know this
well here's an option you can get a
hundred acres in new hampshire for like
200 grand
and then just uh start getting to it
start working the free state project is
social security for people who don't
believe in social security so what do
you what do you think's going to happen
um
if i mean what's the ultimate goal free
state new hampshire secedes or what so
the the project takes no stance on
secession um the like so the idea is
again just get people here um i think
this is my and i'm not giving my
personal opinion like
i'm totally cool with secession i would
love it if it happens i think there's a
huge opportunity to simply push
nullification right like nullification
gets done a lot what's the most
successful anarchist or libertarian
movement in the united states i don't
want to venture a guess no the amish
yeah yeah the amish don't pay social
security what really yep why not because
they the 200 000 of them got together
and said screw you we're not doing it
wow the amish don't have to participate
in the draft what yeah they're the only
organization they're the only people
exempt from the draft wow yeah so when
you have a
there's an aspect of government that's
like very much sour grapes in terms of
what it wants to control and by that i
mean if the if the government can't
control something it acts like it never
wanted to right right
right and so if you have enough people
who are willing to get together and say
no screw you like people people started
their own city in seattle and there was
not the government will to go in and
control it well until they went to the
mayor's house or or right right but if
you get enough people together in one
place and they're willing to say screw
you like i the federal government is not
going to wage a civil war right and so
like i think if you want to achieve
secession which i'm totally cool with
i'm not trying to this is not like an
anti-succession i support it but like
you can do a lot of things you can say
well we're not going to participate in
these federal programs we're not going
to give you this money we're not going
to collect income tax from new hampshire
residents right and you can play this
sort of game of brinksmanship where
you're pushing it on them to do
something well the reason i ask about
secession is you know
watching what happened what we're seeing
in the economy right people need to
understand the m1 money stock is just
skyrocketing they they opened up savings
accounts so that everyone can use
savings like checking they removed the
reserve requirements apparently we're
just finding this out from bob murphy
they were removed reserve requirements
for giving out loans which means banks
can literally just be like here's money
whatever we have no idea
yeah the system's on fire right now
here's what happens
we have a lot of people who watch and
their attitude is the system is too
comfortable for me to do anything
differently right i don't want to stand
up and risk my family and my you know my
house and my job i got kids to feed so
i'm not going to to put them at risk for
a political cause
but i think all that they're really
saying is i will not prepare for what is
happening right before me so so i just
want to ask you like what do you think
happens to a new hampshire in the event
of a breakdown of economic trade lines i
mean are people there gonna just farm
their own food and be self-sufficient or
what i mean i think i think new
hampshire could be self-sufficient if if
necessary um i think self-sufficiency
doesn't have to mean that you're doing
everything yourself it's about like how
it can also be part of having a network
you know to do that and you know there's
a huge algorithm community there are a
bunch of farms in new hampshire there
are a bunch of people who are doing
who are doing their own
thing and i'll say to like your point
about like people not wanting to stand
up i have some sympathy to that like
it's hard to go first but one of the
things you can do is get to get together
with you know ten thousand other people
who all wanna go ten thousand right and
then you can all act together right or
just go to new hampshire now because
people are already there exactly like
you you you'll have a better life
immediately you'll get to live with
people who share your values by far the
greatest density of libertarians in the
entire world and like if there's ever
going to be something that happens like
you're there you're going to be a part
of it you don't i and like i'm not
trying to knock being brave i think
people who are willing to be brave who
are willing to put their their head on
the line i think they're awesome and a
lot of these people are my heroes uh my
personal heroes but if if you're saying
like hey i don't want to be that guy but
i still want to win the free state
project's also a very good choice you
know because you'll you'll still get to
be a part of it but you don't have to be
the very first guy and get your head
chopped off so let's let's take a look
at the you know
the economy from a more libertarian
perspective i guess your thoughts on you
know everything i mentioned about the
banking system what they've been doing
obviously you know ian talks about the
fed a lot we we criticize this system
but like what's your view of what's
going on with this i mean i think it's i
think it's very messed up i think it's
clear that there's like a lot of
inflation happening i mean as a
libertarian like my perspective on this
is like you want free banking you want a
competition in currencies like let let
the best currency win allow there to be
allow there to be competition in terms
of how currencies are going to be
provided and how they work i mean i
think there's all kinds of interesting
things you can do with money beyond even
bitcoin
that can't be done because of government
uh regulation i think david i like david
friedman had some very interesting ideas
uh you know about how to design uh free
money that was like stable and track the
price of goods um going back to the 70s
and those could be done on the
blockchain uh and and there's all kinds
of things that you could do but there's
no doubt that the system is is very
messed up as to what degree it collapses
i mean i'm not an economist so i'm not
gonna like i'm not gonna venture that
but i think it's clear that like you
this is there is like a house of cards
type situation here and to what degree
it collapses you know i don't know
usually all at once yeah especially when
you look at the way then suddenly yeah
with the weight demo it looks like yes
it is collapsing but it also looks like
it's being demolished with this behavior
shutting down the entire almost the
entire economy a large percentage of it
and mass printing of money that's like a
demolition move so i would imagine
like you said well there's that one
there's that meme where they say the
carbon they're trying to reduce is you
never see that i'm no i'm seeing so many
people in prominent positions that don't
understand you can recollect the carbon
from the carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere and turn it into graphene
maybe that's not the issue ian
yeah it's no different the the global
warming stuff is no different than the
covet stuff right like the people who
push it and i'm not trying to say like
global warming is real but like the
people who push it they're pushing it
for reasons of dominating other people
and that's why the focus is so much on
the on the on the communism aspects
that's why they don't care about nuclear
power it's why they don't care about
removing carbon from the environment
right that's why they don't because it's
not about that that's not why they care
i mean they're they're they're like wow
this is a problem and here's what ends
up happening they say okay climate
change is a problem right we got a whole
lot of people cranking out a whole lot
of waste mercury in the waters dead
zones bugs disappearing all this stuff
because humans are affecting the planet
what do we do well
we can reduce carbon in the atmosphere
we can clean up our oceans and like yeah
but that doesn't stop the human behavior
it won't change the fact that humans are
expanding are growing and eating and
consuming and wasting
so how do you stop it in the long run
and they say
authoritarianism
take away their stuff
don't let them live the way they want to
live convince them to live a certain way
that you want them to live because we
are right the problem is as much as we
can look at a lot of the global problems
and be like
yeah these are bad things you know like
like climate change is bad the the dead
zones in the ocean the the constant
droughts whatever you want to attribute
these things to these are bad things
affecting us and we need to be better
into with our environment
why should we blindly trust other people
who just think they're smarter or better
that's ultimately the problem there was
a quote we read i forgot the guy's name
maybe you guys know where he was like if
you know humans are so dumb that they
need a special class to rule them how
are these individuals who claim to be
better actually any better than the
people they claim are too stupid to rule
themselves so so what ends up happening
is they say the solution isn't to pull
carbon from the atmosphere the solution
is stop the chickens from taking a dump
in their water
or just get rid of those chickens that
are taking a dump in their water it's
it's honestly just like coveted like
it's real and it kills people is is
is the debate and discussion around
covid actually about preventing that no
it's not like climate change is real and
it's going to cause uh changes and
potentially harm to our environment is
the way that climate change is discussed
and the way the policies that are being
proposed is it about solving that
problem no it's not right yeah it's
about preventing the problem rather than
treating the problem the problem's here
the problem is not going away you can't
stop people from pooping they're going
to keep pooping you got to reuse it
unless there's less people but
technically but that doesn't scale
because there will always be more people
that's not true well they will continue
to reproduce unless you sterilize the
population and make it close that's
that's not true ian we're we're uh i
believe in the united states they're
below replacement now yeah yeah and
japan's been below replacement for some
time greece and europe yeah most of us
is below replacement free staters are
above replacement oh snap is that true
what is it globally you don't know breed
them for freedom
are you joking or what i don't know i
got three i'm doing my part i'm kind of
looking at like the ocean cleanup this
is boyan slats project in the pacific
they're cleaning up the great garbage
patch the gyre and they did this it's on
my twitter page um this amazing they
found all this trash this is uh from one
run and it's not even from america this
is from the middle of the pacific ocean
and they dumped it and he was like we're
160 thousandth of the way there we're
going to clean this up and that's like
80 years away if this doesn't even scale
which it will and the problem is that
garbage didn't come from america from
there from the entire planet it came
from our species it mostly comes from
china and india and and southeast asia
and that and that part we know that so
there's no stopping this from happening
we're going to keep dumping in the water
that's been it's not we it's it's it's
humans i'm saying humans are going to
continue to dump in the water we just
need to figure out how to reuse the
stuff i think you need to be more
specific because
when greta tunberg comes out and looks
at one of the most environmental and
one of the countries with the most
environmentalists and says how dare you
and doesn't talk about china and india
and these other countries that are just
polluting like crazy we're not going to
solve the problem especially if china's
1.4 billion people the united states and
the west who are actually
environmentally conscious and the ones
leading the charge against climate
change they're in decline i to be honest
if i have to be the world's custodian
i'll do it i don't want to clean up
everyone else's mess but if that means
that's what we need to do to survive
i'll do it the problem is ian you can't
legislate for china no so in the united
states
where we already banned plastic straws
even though we're not contributing for
the most part to these big garbage
patches and then we go to china in these
international agreements and say you
agree not to do this today you bet we
agree not to do this and they say we
don't care we're not gonna listen to
them we're gonna do whatever we want
yeah well in a way waste can become very
profitable because if you can break down
the plastic back into sugar or into oil
you can reuse it so it becomes a
commodity i think that's way to
spark cleanup
are they are they i'm i'm not a climate
scientist are they are they related like
is like
like litter and waste is not necessarily
the thing that's causing climate change
isn't climate change mostly be driven by
being driven by like the use of fossil
fuels yeah mostly methane and carbon
dioxide i think which is carbon mostly
carbon ch4 is methane i think you know
the issue with climate change is that
it's a very specific claim
very very narrowed down to humans
producing too much carbon causing the
climate to change when the real thing we
talk about because we had you know with
chris martinson on is just ecosystem
stresses and potential collapse yeah i'm
not look climate change i get it but
it's one one facet of
we have dead zones in the gulf of mexico
where chemical runoff creates this patch
with no oxygen in the water so nothing
lives
we have fisheries that are so overfished
that jellyfish are coming in and the
people start eating jellyfish it's kind
of gross but i guess they do
these are the problems we face you know
the windshield phenomenon bug
populations being decimated uh
colony collapse disorder bees our
pollinators are are disappearing it is
not just the one thing
it is in my view
when you get eight billion people
consuming and producing tons of waste
even though we still have massive
amounts of space in this planet where
humans aren't you still have a
disproportionate amount of waste that
isn't being absorbed by the ecosystem
quickly enough that's the big issue now
how we solve that well it would be great
if we had like a real green new deal you
know in my opinion where it was actually
like hey we all agree to like stop
spending money on dumb wars and stuff
and then decide to just hire people and
do uh
nuclear energy investment and energy
research infusion carbon recognition
instead the only thing we can get is for
one republicans are totally opposed to
this and it'll never happen to
republicans and then when the democrats
finally come around aoc is like i
propose a green new deal and i'm like oh
okay i'm listening and she goes free
college for minorities and i'm like what
that's making the problem worse yeah if
you're if you're complaining about
immigrant if you're complaining about
america producing too much carbon and
then you're saying bringing more people
into america where they will use more
carbon the left is literally just
arguing to make the problem worse and
there is almost no one in this country
saying we should have more nuclear
energy we should have modern
advancements in
say that yeah
yeah so what do we end up with
yeah the planet's still uh in trouble
humans are our disproportionate force on
this planet and it's not going to get
done through the democrats because
they're too worried about you know
minorities not getting health care i
guess
it's not going to get done by either
them and it's not gonna get done by the
by the libertarians either so no for
sure i mean i you know i i will to give
at least like a little bit of an
optimistic spin like and i think a lot
of the pollution stuff where we're
actually like damaging ecosystems i
think that stuff's pretty bad but in
terms of like climate change being this
existential threat i'm skeptical of some
of that um i think that like
so i don't know if it's like scott adams
like rule about slow-moving disasters
like i think human beings are actually
like very good at solving these kinds of
problems and i think that a lot of the
hysteria
i'm not saying that's not real but
similar to covet a lot of the hysteria
is driven by a desire to to create
changes to subjugate people that the
people creating the hysteria don't like
no no exactly why is it that aoc's green
new deal had more to do with social
justice than a green new deal because
that's not her agenda her agenda is not
the climate or the planet her agenda is
identitarianism
so she'll hold up a big thing that says
climate and then everyone says i would
like to buy on to your climate plan yeah
because they don't actually read it she
decided it's like racism she abused uh
what's that guy's name
uh
roosevelt's uh new deal she just abused
the name just reused it like this the
stupid media culture where they keep
making sequels to dumb stuff you know
here's not a nude that's if i go if i go
to if i go to the store and they i see
in the newspaper and it says you know um
special
moon boots you wear them and you can
jump two feet higher than normal it's a
kid's toy and then i go there and i buy
it it's a skateboard i can be like i
open the box and there's a skateboard
and i'm like this is not what you
advertised you actually i can i can file
a claim against that the government
recognizes you've lied but the
politicians that's all they do literally
everything they have as the patriot act
are you a patriot right now we can spy
on your bathroom here's a libertarian
solution to this problem that will
literally never happen like most
libertines
[Laughter]
and it's make politicians make actual
concrete predictions about the effects
of their legislation so like literally
when you pass the bill you have to say
what it's going to accomplish and you
have to make predictions this is going
to this is going to reduce carbon by
this amount this is going to create you
know this specific amount of jobs or not
that the government can necessarily
create jobs but the point is like you
have to make specific predictions and
then you judge did it actually happen
and you make them make concrete uh
predictions you know i found there's two
types of problems or at least in this in
this
analogy there's two types of problems
there's problems like
you can solve them by making them not
happen that's like your son hits your
daughter smacks your daughter you say no
don't do that don't ever do that again
and then he stops
but then there's problems like global
warming creating waste you can't tell
people to stop creating waste that's not
an option in this situation it's an
endemic issue
you can consider it not a problem it's
not problems aren't bad they're there to
have problem solution it's in math it's
not they're not bad
but this isn't a problem that can be
solved by stopping the behavior we need
to well you need to alter the solution
well i think you need to actually adjust
the cost like and it's much more
straightforward in the case of waste
where you can like track it down and
attribute the blame and say hey
hey whoever is dumping this stuff you
need to pay this amount of money to fix
the problem i actually think from a
libertarian perspective the hardest one
is something like climate change where
it's like it's quite unclear what the
externality is of me burning a fossil
fuel of a gallon of gas what was that
externality what was the cost to it
there there are people who argue that
it's not even clear that it's a negative
externality there are some people who
argue that the earth getting warmer is
actually better for humans and i'm not
endorsing that view necessarily with
other people i've seen evidence that
we're still at the end of the last ice
age but because the comets hit earth 13
000 years ago that melted all the ice it
doesn't seem like we're in an ice age
but we're actually still in an ice age
coming out of it which is why things are
warming and by the way it's from utah uh
new hampshire getting warmer is not bad
for new hampshire so from a
self-interested right
right it's not bad to have no glaciers
on earth it might be great yeah it's i
mean i mean seriously it's not like it's
it's not clear like we're we're a lot of
the climate change stuff is from the
stat from accepting that the current
status quo
is what's best like cities on the coast
yeah right and and obviously there would
be costs to moving or adjusting things
or damming things but like it's not
clear that uh you know uh an average
earth temperature of two degrees celsius
higher is actually
worse for humans than the current
temperature i think but fear that floods
and things is legit fear of flooding
fresh water into the ocean killing life
is legit but it doesn't mean it's going
to be worse after it happens fishery
collapse is a bigger problem and so this
is the issue with almost all political
debate you get
you know two two people and one's like
climate change is a problem the other
person's like oh climate change not a
big deal meanwhile the problem is
actually much larger people hyper focus
on an issue because they want that to be
like the core so for instance right now
the cdc is saying you know new evidence
suggests that covet can cause premature
birth and so they're recommending women
get vaccinated
and the story is that the cdc's had
pregnant people instead of pregnant
women and so i'm like there's your
culture war no one talking about the
risk to pregnancies now if you don't
trust the cdc well that's you and your
trust you can go to your doctor and
figure that out but the story instantly
turned into a culture war debate and not
a medical issue
and that's what we get often in this in
in politics they can't help it's just
they can't help themselves they just
these people can't help themselves and
it's again just more evidence that
when and they know when they're doing it
like that clearly harms if your goal is
to get people vaccinated then when you
say pregnant people and you talk about
like you've just set off
maybe a majority of the population
because i can't believe that many people
are actually on board with pregnant
people particularly yeah it's a
microscopic uh minority but if you're
targeting the group
that is the skeptical and they also
overlap with those who don't like the
phrase pregnant people
it's almost like they intentionally said
that just to rile people oh yeah they do
um you mentioned fishery collapse is a
big problem of the oceans and i agree
with you there's evidence that if you
look into what's called iron
fertilization where you distribute iron
oxide dust into the ocean it regrows
plankton
lots and lots of that's what plankton
eats and then massive fish booms so we i
think we can regrow the fish population
pretty easily there was a i don't want
to call him crazy because he might be a
hero but there was a guy who did that i
don't know i don't know i was just
looking at this right now yeah did that
work i haven't looked that he said it
did they have like a 20 or more than
they expected like
he lost his job
yeah it's incredible
let's uh let's talk about where this
partisanship takes us because we got
this this is um this may be laugh let me
let me larry oh sorry to interrupt 50
million to 226 million fish the salmon
catches this is from uh brian wagon
nexbigfuture.com yeah immense recovery
of salmon population from these
experiments so let's let's talk about
where we end up going when you have this
hyper partisanship we have larry sabato
red alert
52 percent of trump voters somewhat or
strongly favor blue states seceding to
form a separate country
41 percent of biden voters want the red
states to do the same
strongly 25 percent of trump voters
strongly feel this way and 80 of biden
voters
just look at look at the report
and uh that's
basically it
more than half of trump supporters are
like democrats go do your own thing
almost half a democrat saying the same
thing i i think it's beautiful and i can
be unlike some other libertarians in
this regard in the sense that like i
don't view libertarianism as like some
objectively correct philosophy i view it
as the way that i want to live right
like i think it's bad that communists
aren't allowed to be communist i think
they'll be very unhappy i don't think
they're they're but i'm not trying to
take it away from them i don't think
that they're wrong right i think they'll
be very very happy yeah i really really
i hope they are i hope they are like
look at california yeah they vote for
the same thing over and over no matter
how bad it gets because they like it
it's good for them they can have it i'm
out i'm not gonna be there so like let's
let people sort themselves out let's let
people live according to their values
like we'll all be happier so i you know
i think that's a huge white pill i think
we should be optimistic when we hear
that well i certainly think that you
know people have mentioned the peaceful
divorce because it's the the alternative
to a violent separation so yeah
definitely and be it uh texas or new
hampshire
i i'm i'm all for self determination it
would it would be really interesting we
actually had a debate on what would
happen
with texas and new hampshire if they
tried to secede we talked a bit about
new hampshire we were like manchester
will get occupied by the feds the major
urban center so they're not going to let
that go the roads would be shut down
what do you think would happen if new
hampshire said yo we out
uh i'm i'm actually quite skeptical of
the federal government's ability to like
do something strong here
at least anything strong in the sense of
like actually sending in troops actually
exerting force i think if the federal
government was against it you'd much
more likely see a response that's like
and i'm not saying that this wouldn't be
very impactful but like attempting to
shut down trade attempting to shut down
the borders outside of the state or
attempting to make things hard on people
going in and out rather than actually i
think i think there is zero chance
regardless of what state succeeds that
there that there would be troops sent in
well what do you what do you think the
fed's maybe not zero but uh what what do
i think they would do
some of the things i'm talking about
right like i think they would attempt to
make it hard for people to get in and
out i think that's like plausible so in
the surrounding states they'd set up
checkpoints
yeah on the roads and stuff like that
that'd be like 995 north yeah yeah which
we have to leave as federal government
property oh all the freeways are federal
well no no i mean maine needs to be able
to get to the rest of the u.s so and
then there's all the federal buildings
and federal employees the post office no
those are those are ours
the post office yeah no we're gonna take
those
exactly someone was like ian why are you
so hard on because i think it's a
terrible idea to be like we out um i am
into other ways i'll mention in a minute
but someone was like why are you so down
on it these people that want us to see
don't want to take anything and i was
like well they want to take land they
want the united the federal government's
land well we'll get we'll distribute it
to the population like what happened in
afghanistan i mean so like the people in
new hampshire will be that much richer
because we'll get to take all this
federal property distribute it
amongst the citizens i guess i guess i
feel like any kind of seizure of federal
property could get violent really fast
yeah maybe we'll pay them look you know
i i'm gonna be like i think the play is
concentrate people leverage
nullification and then if the federal
government gets aggressive with you
then you push secession but i'm all for
i'm not like i'm for succeeding now i'll
do it tomorrow what i've been thinking
about is creating a parallel system that
can operate through the united states
federal government without it
so like a new economy that works
alongside go for it sorry i want people
to see this image right here that just
pulled up
this is a post office in tilton new
hampshire
and uh i just think you know when you
say we'll take it
it reminds me of fort sumter
you know the union troops are there and
you've got all these post offices so i'm
just is is it going to be you know like
the historic battle of tilton i'm
trolling a little bit when i say when i
say that we'll take it i think the goal
is to keep it as peaceful as possible so
if we need to buy the property from the
federal government then we can buy it
the post office there's a whole bunch
and then there's military bases yeah
so
would be really interesting to see what
would happen i think
if anything did happen it would probably
be this weird pseudo secession where the
federal government would still operate
within the borders of new hampshire
completely and totally as they normally
do
i think that's the kind of thing that
would lead to conflict though well what
would happen is like you mentioned with
the amish they don't pay social security
tax or whatever the people of new
hampshire would basically vote and just
be like you know we out the federal
government would be like i guess
we're still going to keep using these
bases in this land and people in new
hampshire are going to be like don't
care but you can't get taxes from us
anymore yeah i'll take that deal
wasn't there there was a famous story
about a family in new hampshire they
didn't pay taxes do you remember that
story
yeah i can't remember the name but uh
they they ended up getting in like a
standoff with the federal government and
they yeah that's crazy yeah
so what happens when you have mass
non-compliance for how many people it's
like 1.3 million people or something
into place like new hampshire yeah
i think you win when you have mass
non-compliance that's what i think
happens like you'll have a siege so
it'll seem like you win at first and
then you'll slowly be choked out by like
economy and no travel no flight paths
over the thing no if you have pollution
that goes over the borders boy are you
gonna pay for that
i think i think i don't think you
understand what new hampshire is like
i think you're imagining new hampshire
is like new york with massive urban
requirements in this like very dense
like it's very difficult to get food you
can't grow food anywhere
new hampshire may be like manchester
it's harder to do but most of the state
is just like
trees
and people are gonna have are they gonna
homestead i'd imagine also you have
ports so like even if they control the
roads it's much harder to you know
actually unless they're gonna like again
they'd have to start you know shooting
down boats in international waters that
are from other countries and from other
places and saying they can't come into
the port it is american uh us territory
though isn't it because of long island
the water is controlled by the us uh
i mean i'm sure again
this is this is all like very difficult
to kind of like very hypothetical very
good
to kind of to kind of larp out um i
think that like oh no no direct ocean
access yeah oh yeah yeah 13 miles of
coast um so not the largest amount of
coast but enough um and look i think i
think there's so much i'm not i'm not
trying to talk down secession i just
think there's so much more that you can
do you don't have to jump from where we
are today all the way to secession look
the more libertarians control the state
government they can repeal an incredible
amount of state laws they can make it
very hard for the federal government to
operate and we've already we already
have a roadmap for this
and and this is exactly what i was
talking about with this sour grapes
thing like
how many states have nullified
federal marijuana laws does the federal
government send in the or immigration
laws
sanctuary cities right all kinds of
cities literally nullify the federal
government doesn't send in troops to
stop that and so that's what you do like
and this isn't quite as sexy as
succeeding tomorrow i understand so i i
i also want to talk about the the sexier
topic but you just go piece by piece and
so rather than going for trying to eat
the apple in one bite which causes a a
conflict you take one bite of the apple
and then they don't come out you take
another bite in the apple and you just
keep doing that until you've eaten the
whole apple and when each step is so
small that
force seems like a disproportionate
response they don't do it and then all
of a sudden you've eaten the entire
apple and so i think that's a much
better strategy yeah well so uh
what is there like a five-year plan do
you like or a better better question is
like what do you think happens in five
years
i think that libertarians continue to
concentrate i think we continue to have
more political power i'll talk briefly
about the political power we have
currently we have 40 elected free
staters to the state legislature we have
more than 100 libertarians total and
this is they're graded by a third this
is another one of the institutions in
this massive web of institutions that
are creating the liberty movement
there's an institution called the new
hampshire liberty alliance great
institution to support and they grade
every bill on whether it's libertarian
or not and then they grade
every representative in terms of did
they vote the libertarian way so we have
grades going back 15 years on maybe
longer on every politician and where
they libertarian so when i say there's
100 libertarians i'm saying there are
100 libertarians that got an a they
voted libertarian 90 of the time or more
on the on the bills in 2020. what if i
want a tank
do it i want a tank and i want a 50 cal
full auto i think if anyone deserves a
tank it's you so people don't realize
this but i love it tanks are legal
uh there's and and depending on what
kind of weaponry you have on it and
where you have it's illegal as well it
was it's funny because you often hear
from from these you know democrat
establishment types the authoritarians
about gun control and they're like you
can't own a tank can you and you're like
yes you can you literally can a story i
i think was buzzfeed that wrote this a
guy had a 50 cal full auto on his on a
tank and he was shooting into a lake and
some like some state troopers pulled up
and they were like howdy and he was like
he stops and he's like how can i help
you and they're like this your property
he's like yes it is like have a nice day
and they left
i i'll plug new hampshire highest
machine gun
per capita wow really yeah highest
highest machine gun
auto machine
i'm pretty sure that video of luke with
two full auto
you know new hampshire you see the
picture of luke with his dog and a goat
yeah i hope he has more than one though
you're not supposed to have one goat
right yeah but you know you keep doing
you just keep doing stuff like this and
as we get more political control you get
more people in office you repeal more
laws you do more nullification type
stuff
there's so many clever ways you can do
it where you can just like
you see we're doing this with guns now
where we're basically saying hey federal
agents can't operate in the state
they're just not allowed they'll be
breaking state law and you play these
guys
yeah exactly like it was a big thing in
ohio where they were like if any atf
agent tries to enforce us arrest them oh
yeah something like that right so you do
stuff like this and i think this is the
way that you can um you can win what if
we uh bought like 100 acres and then
just told people like have at it i would
be thrilled to to welcome you to the
free state tim i think i mean i wouldn't
we're we're out in west virginia
basically so we we actually are just
finalizing a deal on a big plot of land
um you know freedom city or for damastam
we jokingly call it and we're gonna have
like a recreational facility and we're
gonna be producing a lot of content
doing more shows we have a new show
that's actually already live i guess we
can we can announce the name now because
it's already up isn't it
we'll save it for tomorrow yeah
it is uh but you know we're gonna so we
soft launched it and then we can
officially announce it so we're doing a
bunch of shows and these are like fully
produced podcast editing sound effects
and stuff like that so we want to do
this mini little freedom city in west
virginia
but what if we just bought you know 100
acres in central new hampshire
if there was a group of people who are
willing to go there and just start using
it so i think if you're interested in
that in the chat if you could just sound
off and say yeah i want to i want to
move to new hampshire well is there like
is there like a free like does the free
state project have like land for like
organizational use so the free state
project again it's it's one percent of
the free state movement so the free
state project has like two employees and
a budget of like two hundred thousand
dollars a year okay like it's a small
organization the free state movement
owns like a billion dollars worth of
property in the state and you know and
the total organizational budget of all
the different organizations is in the
like tens of millions or hundreds you
know it's a huge amount of what's
happening so are there real estate
companies that are owned by free staters
that that prioritize free standards that
try to do this kind of thing yeah
they're not explicitly under the
auspices of the free state project
is there a concern like the government
might come after people for sedition or
something
um
when's the last time that happened has
that happened
i mean i think after a long time
i think they're i think they're more
likely to come after you in like oblique
ways like you can look at how they've
targeted like ian freeman over some of
this crypto stuff for the crypto six by
the way um where like they're trying to
say he violated federal money
transmission laws i mean you can look at
how they're coming after me i'm being
sued by the federal government in civil
court um i think they're more likely to
do things in this way where they don't
have to make it explicitly about what
it's actually about
i came up with a little bit we're
spitballing ideas about secession or
what it might be and let me know what
you think about this that if the
government and people kind of laughed at
it because it's not a really well
thought out thing but if uh say new
hampshire were to secede but they set up
a smart contract or some sort of
automated system where if the united
states government federal government met
the terms of these secessionists they
would automatically be re-implemented
back into the
federal system yeah i i think that's a
very clever way to do it where you can
do it with these triggers that's the way
the free state project started by the
way um the free state project like it
wasn't like people were like new
hampshire is awesome let's move there it
started by there's a guy named jason
sorens he wrote this essay and uh
the opening of the essay was basically
the libertarian party is a failure the
liberty the notion of of the libertarian
party ever achieving its agenda in my
lifetime is like literally hopeless you
know i bet all this money that that will
never happen he made this 20-year
prediction 20 years ago it came true uh
just very recently he was completely
correct
and he said that like but there are
enough libertarians in the country that
if we concentrated we could actually
achieve our agenda and the way that
started was people
signed an assurance contract like a
kickstarter and so it started with 5 000
people saying well we're not sure where
we're going to move but we'll all move
to the place that we agree on and then
we'll continue to keep the movement
going from there so there's this whole
selection process
like wyoming was the second state and
alaska i think was the third and they
went through i mean there was a longer
list but that's the way it came out new
hampshire came in first wyoming came in
second and alaska came in third where
they went through and debated all the
possible states and a key target was low
population right new hampshire only has
a million people right so that's part of
why we're able to have such an outsized
effect with only you know 10 000
you know or so
so if
a million and one people move to new
hampshire and then you vote you get
exactly what you want yeah exactly i
don't think you need anywhere near that
number and i i was i was talking to
lydia about this about like you know a
big part of libertarians tend to be
either like they tend to be
independently minded right yeah and so
they they tend to do commit the typical
mind fallacy and model other people as
independently minded it's a big part of
why the libertarian party is such a
failure they're like people make their
decisions as independent rational
animals and they consider the policy and
then our policies are better so they'll
vote for us and it is like the most
absolutely wrong model of how people
actually decide things most people are
agreeable they decide things to feel
like they're being agreeable to feel
like they're getting along and going
along and this is what other people
believe and so when you have it's a is
another way
naseem to labs tyranny of the minority
if you have this small minority of
people that are extremely vocal about
what they believe they pull a ton of
these agreeable people to their
positions and it's a big part of how
we're succeeding it's even how the
libertarians in new hampshire are making
the republican party more
libertarian is because they go in and
they're republicans now and they're
advocating these really libertarian
positions and so they've pulled these
like you know these like trumpian
conservative types to be much more
libertarian because they're there
they're republicans and they're being
loud about what they believe what what's
like a state what's the state budget
like i feel like we could bring billions
of dollars in industry into that state
there's so much money in defecting
there's so much money in for one country
or one state to defect from the not just
the us regime but the global regime
in terms of the way that it shuts down
creative entrepreneurship and all kinds
of other things i i think
you know new hampshire is
not the best choice i think west
virginia is is better oh you're
landlocked though i mean if we're if
we're role-playing all this out that's
true yeah unlocked is bad but the issue
is new hampshire is blue and i'm looking
at their election results i i think that
is a res so new hampshire is a
republican governor 60 of the republican
executive council which is this organ
that other people don't have but it's
part of the executive body republican
senate republican state legislature the
entire state government is red so it was
just like an anti-trump recoil maybe
a lot of new hampshire conservatives do
not did not like trump new hampshire's
like traveling back in time this is one
of the weirdest parts where it's like
they're like decorum and the process and
and rational and we're gonna debate
things and like let's all get along and
so so the kind of like brash style that
trump had was very off-putting to a lot
of yeah that's true
and and i mentioned it all the time like
regular people were like i don't like
the way he talks that hurts them it
helped him in a lot of ways but you know
i look landlocked is a big issue but
it's actually
the other issue is who you're surrounded
by in new hampshire so i had this debate
with luke all the time he's like new
hampshire's the best and i'm like yeah
but who's look what you're surrounded by
canada
and then you got uh massachusetts you
got what's the vermont
vermont's not bad yeah i
i actually think this helps in terms of
acceleration because the truth is like
it's awesome we have people move from
california and all over the all over the
country but the truth is more people
move from closer nearby right and so if
you're in a place like wyoming
where are you pulling people from it's a
big everywhere right right yeah if
you're in new hampshire it's you know
there's a lot of libertarians in
massachusetts and in new york there's a
lot of libertarians in new york exactly
and it's not that hard to move from
those places uh to new hampshire it's a
little more palatable so i actually
think it's it's been a good choice by
the movement to be in this population
center all right i agree with you now i
guess yes okay and look you know we're
going to be the hong kong of america so
as america turns into china we're going
to become hong kong with more guns okay
yeah that's what new hampshire is going
to become it's actually very valuable to
be on the border with canada yeah
especially hey if global warming is real
canada's going to be a tropical paradise
maybe not tropical subtropical it's
going to be a beautiful beautiful
country again even the the the ipcc like
consensus estimate
is like what it's like two to three
degrees c right like it's not it's
things would change but they wouldn't i
hear you got you guys looking for trade
black flies in new hampshire
uh
i i know we're we don't have one of the
most common types of mosquitoes they
don't come that far north oh ah but you
got black flies probably pretty sure
probably so
i know in northern maine so we were
actually looking for a bunch of places
to set up like outside of cities and i
was like maine you know maybe but maine
is insanely expensive and there's like
there's cheaper areas there's limited
infrastructure it's because all the
really rich people go to like the shores
of portland of of maine to get away and
it's just like
yeah you got to be pretty well off for
the most part i was looking at property
and comparing it you know identical
infrastructure substantially cheaper in
the west virginia area than basically
anywhere else
i've been thinking about setting up um
like a university for uh scientists that
want to learn how to use to make
graphene because i don't know if you're
familiar much with graphene but it's
going to be a 21st century steel we're
right about 2029 we're going to start to
see inflex um and i was going to do it
nationally like do it in chicago get the
federal funds to fund it build an
american thing that we manage for 15
years and show all these americans that
get two weeks for free with their tax
money to come and learn how to use it
and then all the graphing we produce is
free for all americans forever and then
after 15 years it becomes a utility and
we just produce and use free and it's
like space elevator travel but we could
do it on a on a state level it makes a
lot more sense yeah let's do it new
hampshire graphing capital of the world
there you go it's gonna happen you gotta
get you gotta get some industry to come
in and um i gotta be honest there's a
lot of very very very wealthy people and
i'm surprised we don't see more of this
i am surprised more wealthy people don't
try to defect but i mean new hampshire
is like that's a thing it has like a
small population and in some ways it can
feel rural but it really has everything
it has a huge tech industry the average
income in new hampshire is like in the
top five for states like it's if the
median income is like 75 000 a year or
something constitutional carry oh yeah
constitutional carry stand your ground
castle doctrine we've got like the best
gun gun laws what's this what's your
state motto live free or die wow
maybe we should slowly start moving
production up to new hampshire yeah and
we mean it like seriously
people mean it it's like people have a
liberty and this is again part of why
the state was chosen like people have a
natural libertarian bias they don't want
to be in your business they don't want
to bother you
new hampshire had the highest vote
percentage for ron paul in in 2012 right
like of of any state in the country i
mean there is a there was a natural
libertarian leaning to the population
well there you go yeah what the future
is what if we like lived there three
months out of the year or something only
in the winter
yeah only in the deepest winter or well
i like that we're centralized right now
we're closer to dc it's it's but i don't
know if that is going to be
necessary look i i think like
whether you would be happy in new
hampshire like listening to this
conversation is like reading a dating
profile and deciding if someone is going
to be your wife okay or husband like
this is a dating profile this is like do
i want to go on a date with this person
it's not do i want to marry them so you
don't have to be convinced that new
hampshire is the best place for you what
you have to do is be curious and then
the next step is you come for a visit
you come check it out you come to pork
fest this summer you buy your tickets
tonight because it's going to sell out
you come you come to liberty forum in
the fall which is not quite as as laid
back as as uh pork fest but it's for
like the people who want to be like i
want to get stuff done i'm a serious
person at new hampshire
nhlibertyforum.com you can buy tickets
right now come for a visit anytime the
fsp will literally be like your personal
tour guide we'll plug you into all the
secret stuff that's not available online
if you contact us we'll teach you about
the secret club and there's a public
calendar but there's also stuff that's
like not on the calendar so you got to
come for a visit you got to get in touch
with us and we'll let you check out the
state and then you can decide if that's
a place you want to be
i don't you know
i don't care if it's west virginia or
wyoming or new hampshire the idea of
like people coming together and so for
at this point it's like the free state
project's been around so long and new
hampshire probably does make the most
sense just based on what's what's
already built and it's you know its
foundation and
man new hampshire is a pretty free place
i see you know luke firing the
flamethrower yeah
he fired at a pork fest this summer
there's a great video
the idea that we could effect government
change is very exhilarating
as an american i'm like as if that
should be anything but the norm but i
don't know what's like the libertarian
political movement in in new hampshire
right now
in the government there yeah so and let
me first say like i agree with you
completely like i i
hated
voting when i lived in philadelphia i
basically didn't do it or i did it like
begrudgingly because you know your
friends are like you have to vote jeremy
you're don't be a bad person
um uh and i'm like happy to vote every
time i go in to vote every single
election i can vote for someone who i
feel like shares my values and wants the
world to be the kind of way that i want
the world to be and that does feel it's
the first time that voting has like felt
good to me in a very long time since
maybe when i was in my early 20s and
actually believed it in a more you know
genuine form
so it's ended a lot of that cynicism uh
and
libertarians run for every kind of
office position office they run as
democrats they run as republicans they
run as libertarians most of them do get
elected as republicans but they get
elected under every party
you only send a libertarian
candidate to congress i agree
i think i think one of the most
important things is to have like a duly
elected like formally elected
libertarian go there
probably talks with republicans i
imagine yeah i mean i i i would love to
see it i mean i think it's i do think
it's really hard to win third party and
i'm looking i'm i'm a supporter of of
the like the libertarian party seems
like it's becoming more libertarian
again with you know with the mises
caucus and dave smith he's awesome and
all of these people who are like you're
really giving this full-throated support
for libertarianism rather than like the
woke neo-liberal party or like whatever
it had become um but i think it is
really hard to win as a third party um i
think that you have whatever that law is
like duverger's law or whatever that
like you know just like it everything
trends towards two parties and so it's
really hard to win as a third party um i
you know so i would love it if a libert
you know i would love it if a
libertarian party candidate could win i
really just want libertarians to win i
don't care what letter is next to your
name yeah
like a libertarian government governor
yeah the there is um so the current he
was a fat past candidate for governor
and he's currently the head of the
school
place organization what's the branch of
government department of the school
department education state yeah
yeah i clearly attended we're deep right
now yeah uh uh anyway he's like super
he's like very libertarian uh and he's
he's decently likely to be the next uh
governor so the current governor is like
he's like libertarian financially but
he's like not as libertarian on other
policies one as a republican win and
then immediately announce you're in the
libertarian party that so we had
republicans do that that's how new
hampshire had three um
libertarians in the state legislature
like four years ago and that was exactly
what they did that's how they did it
they ran us republicans one and they
were like all right we're libertarians
yep
the libertarian party is so wacky though
that's the problem
it's the only way
you know the libertarian party likes to
tout these candidates they're like oh we
have these there's lit they've literally
never won a three-way race literally
never all of their candidates that are
in the state legislature either one and
defected defected whatever changed
parties or they ran a two-party race so
like they have marshall burt and wyoming
he ran libertarian against democrat
without a republican in the race and was
and was able to win
so if you can somehow get it down to two
parties i think the libertarian party
could win and i think it'd be great if
libertarians could run under the
libertarian party like the libertarian
party platform is more libertarian than
the republican platform although in new
hampshire this is another way that
libertarians they're so
i gotta say if you've never been part of
a cabal
you need to get a cabal like cabals are
awesome they're really fun right uh and
so then one of the ways they win is like
they go in and they write the republican
platforms like the republican platform
you can look it up for the republican
platform of new hampshire not nationally
it's like pretty libertarian and if you
look at the scores of state reps the
libertarian ones do better because the
libertarians wrote the republican
platform for the mo not entirely there's
clearly some things in there they didn't
get that they would have left out but
it's much more libertarian than most
republican blood i think we could set up
free software machine learning
algorithms to advise the governor if not
i wouldn't want to act as a governor
because i want a human to make the final
call but i want people to be able to
watch the advisement that the governor
is receiving and then i mean we could
really
create like an art project
yeah i mean i'm actually not fully
getting this idea but like if we need
some sort having one human controlling
all this power is insane to me and i
would love to disperse the power of the
governor amongst many people i don't
know if that's functional for like
split-second decisions but usually
governors don't have to make those
that's like the president
so
but i'm also interested in utilizing ai
to ease the the political thing like you
said you hate voting no one wants to
deal with that we send representatives
because we have to because it's the
least worst system so maybe what if
there was a system where
machine learning just figured out what
people tended towards i'm not saying
this is a good thing i'm saying what
would a system be like if you know
youtube says like man people sure do
love clicking on you know boobs or
whatever so they show you more and more
of that stuff then eventually a human
has to intervene because people are
complaining like this goes against their
values what would a government
government be like if laws changed based
on how people reacted to the system in
place so it was amorphous almost
depends on how good the system is like i
mean i think
i'm socialist probably yeah i mean i'm
like yeah i'm i'm like relatively
anti-democratic and like anti-uh you
know populist i think like generally the
more democratic we've become the less
libertarian we've become one of my
unpopular beliefs among libertarians
i'll say it now because i am one of
those highly disagreeable types who says
these things anyway it's like i think
libertarians need to face the fact that
most people aren't libertarian most
people don't want to be libertarian most
people
don't actually like freedom and personal
responsibility and individual choice but
they don't so you need to level up the
free state project and not just attract
libertarians but also attract people by
saying if you want to be a sheep in the
flock protected by a strong sheepdog and
a shepherd
new hampshire's place for you just do as
you're told vote the way we tell you and
we'll keep you safe yeah i i i think
there is a way that that happens and
almost kind of already does though not
quite that explicitly but there are all
kinds of libertarians that are like
large employers right and and a large
employer has the chance to kind of like
they are
kind of playing that role not always but
you know they're giving you a job but
they also have this chance to kind of
push political perspectives they have
this chance to influence the way that
you think and if you're agreeable you
kind of am my boss is good to me and so
on and so when you have these
libertarians and this is part of this is
what the libertarian party doesn't
understand but what i think the free
state movement does whether implicitly
or explicitly is like the way you
actually change people's minds is you
become an accomplished person you attain
status in your community by being a good
person by being a good father by being a
contributor by being a volunteer by
being successful you know um
by having your life together and when
you do all of those things people look
up to you and then people copy and adapt
your values and what you believe because
they see well look at that person look
at how he is or she is and i want to be
more like that have you considered just
um using your funding for propaganda
campaigns to just trick people into
supporting you
well i mean again people do the
libertarians do run under every party we
don't have that much money our money is
going to get people here we're the bus
right so mom you know get people on the
bus but so i remember reading about like
all these rich people got a cruise ship
so they could do weird stuff in
international waters that was illegal
for like their businesses or something
where are the billionaires to be like
let's just go to new hampshire and fund
this so that we can have laissez faire
puerto rico yeah a lot of them went to
puerto rico after the hurricane and
started to rebuild a new utopian bitcoin
utopia so i heard that's the last i
heard of it a billionaire could conquer
new hampshire as it were you know
come with massive funding like
everything you mentioned about the low
population and people you like okay for
all billionaires listening uh please
contact me
2020 tax revenue was 800 million in in
this state i mean we could bring
billions and especially with the amount
of money that's been printed lately
yikes geez we could bring a lot of money
into that state it's not really about
the money though it's about what we
produce the production well really all
that needs to happen is employers need
to relocate to the state
you if you've got you know any amount of
employers and you relocate to new
hampshire you bring those employees
employees with you not an easy thing for
everybody but if you can do that that
not only brings more money to the state
but it brings those people and their
taxes and
and it just makes the economy of new
hampshire better wouldn't it be funny
like just imagine
you know 100 years from now you look at
a topographical map of the united states
and it's like everything looks kind of
the same but new hampshire is a massive
megatropolis with like flying cars oh
that's the future have you ever seen uh
this i love this video it's from i think
it's called grace still plays is that
the guy the youtuber i don't know this
guy he was playing a game called city
state i think it's called
and you you basically are building a
city state you can choose to have taxes
low taxes high taxes you can choose to
regulate or deregulate and things like
that and so he decides to play this game
where he's like i'm just gonna it's
gonna be anarchy it's gonna be whatever
i don't care no rules no taxes
and what he thought was gonna happen was
it was gonna be poverty and chaos and
it's a hilarious video because he's like
what's happening and like there's no
poor there's zero poverty everyone's
wealthy ski resorts keep popping up all
over the place and he's like what and
all he did was say no taxes no
government no intervention and it just
everyone lived in luxury city state
two's out by the way awesome game shout
out to raptor games on youtube well i i
think this is another thing that some
libertarians can miss because like most
everyone lives in luxury now
right like seriously i'm not i'm not i'm
not trying to say they're
psychologically healthy or they're
physically healthy but in terms of like
if you could work like a minimum wage
job and in terms of what you have
available to you in terms of like
quality food
technology all these things it is
a better life than most people have had
throughout history the difference is
that human beings some a lot of
libertarians don't feel this way but
most other people do
they have they experience a psychic pain
when other people have more than them
they literally like they do
they this is part of what libertarian
libertarians tend to not experience this
a lot of them don't believe me when i
say this but that's why that's what so
much of this stuff is about that's what
the green new deal is about that's why
socialists don't actually care if their
policies would make people worse off
because it's about bringing people
closer together because they're pained
by the fact that other people have that
why do so many people hate why do so
many environmentalists hate elon musk
who's doing more to make the world green
than like anyone else because he's
really rich yeah right why is there so
much hatred for jeff bezos who again
gives lots of 15 20 an hour jobs that
anyone can go and get right
because he's really rich and like there
are a lot of people i don't have this
feeling i don't have it myself but there
are a lot of people who just have that
feeling and simply the distance
in resources
makes that person back so the envy i
guess is what yeah maybe i used to feel
that one of the great tables in l.a and
i'd wait on i was just telling the story
with you guys last couple nights ago
last night and i would just get it i'd
be like gosh i wish i could not have to
work in the middle of the day and go
walk my dog with my sandals on and eat
30 meals
every day five days a week and i just go
about my business thinking like i want
that'd be awesome
let me get back to it you know just
dealing with my reality but i felt it
you know it's not as much anymore but
you know i've also done more that i'm
proud of so that's part of it yeah
that's socialism it's envy uh people not
realizing that uh you have better dental
care today than rockefeller did
he's got the this this massive wealth
the wealthiest guy and you can get
better you got air conditioning he
didn't you've got a refrigerator luxury
items we've got a t you got a tv you got
a big screen tv you got vr headsets for
a couple hundred bucks
you know i was talking about this a
while back
someone when someone said something to
occupy they were like you know we're the
first generation that's going to be
worse off than our parents
our parents generation and i was like my
dad didn't have a tv or a phone
like because they were not it was like
tvs were expensive
now people got tvs in their pockets and
you got to pay the bill for that like if
you if you could take this device back
in history and it still somehow worked
it would be worth like all the world's
wealth like all of it or half of it or
something like tremendous if you
downloaded the contents of wikipedia
onto this device
and had like a charging cable and a
battery pack that could easily recharge
it because or you know just a wall
charger you brought it back 50 years
it'd be worth 100 trillion dollars
because it's it's now to be fair future
information is worth a different moment
but like let's say
all it had
let's say you downloaded wikipedia's
a wikipedia database an encyclopedic
database from 1970 identical information
to what that is time nothing beyond
their their level of knowledge the
device would still be worth billions of
dollars trillions yeah yeah trillions
because they could be like i can pull up
all of the information we currently know
of 1970 and no one else can
oh yeah governments would look for it it
would be oh yeah it's it's fascinating i
love like these the shows that superhero
shows you know heroes did it where they
like you know how do you handle people
with powers and people who don't so in
like x-men they have the mutant registry
act because they're like this is
dangerous these mutants and i i think
about
there's this uh
this is a common trope in sci-fi and i
think it's just often said the reason
why aliens would not give humans
technology is what do you think they
would do with it they'd wage war what do
you think would happen if you went to uh
um you know a village in africa and said
here's a stockpile of you know m16s or
something and crates full of ammo they
would be like we're going to use it to
empower ourselves and we're going to you
know
take care of our enemies so what happens
in the u.s or i should say in the world
is that typically all this technology
arises
simultaneously in different ways so you
do end up with world war and conflict in
crisis but for the most part we're
always kind of you know at an equal
level what would happen if you came and
gave this this power of knowledge to a a
you know a prior generation to us it's a
cell phone we look at pictures of cats
and we argue with strangers on the
internet
back then it would be one of the most
powerful weapons the world had ever seen
the fact that someone could be like i
can know everything humans can know like
that yeah the envy thing seems like an
emergent phenomenon because obviously
people have enough i mean we have enough
to become super gods if any one person
wanted to study everything on the
internet and remember it memorize it
you'd be
yeah i mean i think it's driven by
evolution like no one wants to be like
we've always lived in some sort of
social hierarchies throughout our
evolution and and everyone wants to be
at the top and no one wants to feel like
they're at the bottom and so it's for
the people at the bottom of any sort of
hierarchy they want to gang up on and
take down the
the person at the top i think it's i
think it's something that's been i think
primates do it i think all kinds of
other social animals
do it i think you know another point of
evidence in this favor is like if you
look at happiness research
people in countries that are much poorer
than the us like aren't substantially
less happy than than people in the u.s
like the distribution of happiness is
like pretty similar well because it's
not really about
how well off you i mean it plays a role
i'm not saying they're literally the
same but it's much more about you hey if
you're doing well in society this is
also why you there's you see this
research sometimes it's like oh you know
um
if everyone made 80 000 a year they'd be
happy look at this research once once
people make this amount of money they're
much happier it's not about the money
it's not about the resources it's about
that once you're at that a certain level
you you experience happiness from being
you know having achieved the success
that distances you from others and this
is like a kind of like cold and
uncomfortable way to talk about but i
think it's the truth i will i will say
though having a little bit of money have
enough money to eat whatever i want
whenever i want and to sleep as late as
i want is life-changing yes when you're
talking about like abject poverty like
start there's clear differences there so
i'm not i'm not talking about like quite
at that level there are clear
differences i once read that a
paraplegic a year after their accident
and a lottery winner a year after
winning register the same levels of
happiness we have we experienced these
hedonic adjustments jonathan haight has
some really good research on this topic
we're going to do a hard segue the
hardest of hard segways do it i'm sorry
because i have to
because there was a trend on twitter my
friends i give you
jenk yuger
of the young turks claiming he could
beat joe rogan in a fight
all right okay that's mma celebrity
match just uh just for everybody you
know uh jenk is an overweight
progressive uh youtube host and joe
rogan is not only an mma commentator but
he used to fight mma and he trains and
he has a gym
and he is massively ripped but we have
this tweet
mr m says
i'll make a one thousand dollar donation
to your trash network or your or your
charity of choice to see you call rogan
who is not only the most successful
podcast in history but also a black belt
in mma a loser to his face
and jan kuger said deal
easiest one thousand dollars i've ever
made you think he's going to assault me
sure whatever that's incredibly dumb but
also wouldn't work i'm much larger than
joe and i've fought my whole life i'd
end him but grown-ups don't do that i'll
send you the p.o box to send the check
later
i'll end him
this is wow a whole new level of stupid
but come on man is this is this this is
the political discourse we get in this
country yes let me let me let me pull up
we got we got another tweet here let me
see if it loads
jenkins says if joe rogan believes the
government is violating your bodily
autonomy is that the government
violating your bodily autonomy is
tyranny then he must be furious about
anti-choice christian mullahs in his
country if he isn't then he's an effing
hypocrite sucking up to his right wing
audience out of either stupidity or
cowardice except i'm pretty sure joe
rogan is pro-choice pro-ubi pro bernie
sanders
this is what these people don't get
jank uger is plastic
he represents
the the the non-player character that
dominates our political discourse i for
instance
pro-choice
vax mandates are wrong because it's a
liberty-minded approach not a
traditional value-minded approach but
jen doesn't know or care and so the
parent factions the the democrats and
the republicans now the republicans
mostly not so much because trump really
just splattered that whole party
changing it
very
different nowadays
but the establishment democrats only
seem to recognize dichotomies
so jen kuger goes on his show and says
either you agree with us
you're on our side or no matter what
else you're wrong even if what you're
saying is scientifically true or
factually correct doesn't matter and so
they'll come out and they just what's
the point of this tweet did you just
watch joe rogan's podcast
well this is i mean this is the point of
the tweet
do we talk about it on tv
but but but good i'm you know i
understand that and i'm fine with it you
know why we need to explain to people
who are watching give them something
they can share and say my friends you
deserve actual political debates what
jenk is saying here
most likely is driven by i i will say
hanlon's razer never attribute to malice
that which can be explained by
incompetence or attributed to
incompetence perhaps he's just
not that smart however genkuger runs a
multi-million dollar network that's
massive and you need to have abilities
and passion and drive to do something
like that so that says to me jenk knows
he's misleading his audience he knows
he's pushing trash to fill their minds
with garbage that will not move this
country forward rogan's a black belt in
jiu jitsu i believe he i know he's a
kickboxer i don't know if he practices
but i mean i think chank just doesn't
understand that
if he's really being serious here it
sounds like he's like a high school
athlete who's like in their 30s or 40s
and is a little overweight and still
talks about how badass they are yeah
i don't know i don't know chang i don't
know maybe he's a great fighter i don't
know he's a union buster
this is the problem we have
the young the young turks are on youtube
tv they're propped up by youtube they
have massive investment and they are as
fake as they come this is this is
they're saying i used to love him man
and then in 2007 2006 they were like
speaking out against the war in iraq
he was revolutionary in a good way it's
not even i don't it's look
i don't know if you've seen this but
have you noticed a change in people like
something changed yeah people like like
like jang for instance you know uh i've
known him for a long time and not my
friends or anything but you know i've
had me on a show a couple of times i saw
him at vidcon several years ago and he
walked up and he was like how's it going
we show cans and we talked about youtube
and metrics and i was doing my youtube
channel and i was doing what i was doing
and then two years later at politicon
he's screaming in my face just like
screaming at me and i'm like why are you
yelling at me like dude what's going on
i should clarify joe's not a kickboxer
taekwondo that's what i meant to say
taekwondo oh really
he won a uh tournament like in his late
teens early twenties and then he kind of
got out of the game after that he had
too much dude is ripped yeah he's a
maniac he loves taking out but so so
something happened to people man and i
don't i don't know what yeah i'm not
this isn't like a strong explanation but
i think part of it does have to do with
social media
and the way that it's sort of like
i i i to me that matches up with the
timeline of like the politics has gotten
much more divisive like democrats and
republicans have moved away from the
middle and are like much more outside of
the middle but have you seen the pew
research the the trends on this or yeah
it's democrats not republicans
republicans are slightly more moderate i
thought it was democrats more than
republicans but republicans also did it
republicans shifted leftward a great
deal from like you know during the 2000s
into the early 2010s yeah and then moved
only a little bit to the right okay so
depending on what time frame you're
using but based on where republicans
were in the 90s into the 2000s they're
actually much further left than yeah
than they traditionally had their
progressives driving the speed limit and
one on and so on right exactly yeah uh
yeah so but it definitely does like it
incentivizes conflict it discourages us
seeing uh the other side uh and it's
also like created this phenomenon where
like we're living in these like separate
realities where they're like you know
who is who is like who are these people
that both sides still trust you know
there's basically no one none
so my favorite was i mentioned this for
many of you may have heard this but i'll
just you know just so you know when i
went on russell brand's show and he
asked me i was in russell brandt's show
he asked me about civil war
and you know i typically view this as
people are like they think they're gonna
get me as though like i'm some shock
jock being like civil war and like bang
on the table when i'm actually like
going through all of the details the
princeton professor the atlantic
articles the the conversations around
thucydides trap and what it means fourth
and fifth generational warfare all of
these very like you know specific
examples of why we are facing some kind
of civil conflict then you've got i'm
like first and foremost we had two
shootouts in the pacific northwest
between the left and the right i mean
that's kinetic conflict it's been going
on for years and getting worse
and then you have the storming of the
capital a lot of stuff the comment
section was hilarious people on the
right saying tim's a leftist people on
the left saying tim's
and i'm like well there you go there's
no middle there isn't for any real
conversation but the interesting thing
is libertarians are kind of like in the
middle because they're like all i care
about is freedom do you care about
freedom so i suppose i'll put it this
way
when i look at uh when we have
libertarians on the show with
conservatives they agree on on so much
but the libertarians on the left do not
agree and the conservatives and liberals
do not agree and it really does feel
like
the overwhelming majority of the left as
we describe it be an establishment or
leftist is authoritarian masquerading as
libertarian because
no one will come out and claim to be an
authoritarian no one will do it it's not
going to win you any favors but then you
see people like hassan [ __ ] you know
you see the young turks you see vosh in
favor of rule by edict the president
issuing a decree and then everyone being
forced to adhere to it and they're
celebrating it
that's the definition of
authoritarianism
yeah what's the does everyone know the
dude quote i could never do it right
like when i'm weaker than you i ask for
you to follow the principles and then
when i'm stronger than you like i i
don't adhere to the principles because
it's good good for me i'm i'm yeah i
look it up but that but that's that's
exactly what the uh that's exactly the
phenomena and i don't i don't know how
much of it is like conscious i think
part of it is that like human beings are
deceitful to themselves and so like when
they're on the on the losing side and
the underside they have this like
genuine feeling that principles ought to
be important and when they're on the
winning side and the dominant side they
have this feeling that i know principles
don't matter like what matters is
accomplishing my objective i have the
the dune quote from frank herbert the
writer children of dune when i'm weaker
than you i ask for freedom because that
is according to your principles but when
i'm stronger than you i take away your
freedom because that is according to
mine to mine
to my principles yeah sorry i got caught
up in the middle that was a little
anticlimactic so pop-up but i think i
think that's like the phenomenon you
know we need a new word because geez a
lot you know so the the right says
communism the left says capitalism
there's a corruption element there the
left says fascism
we need a new word you know what's
happening is a new type of prior
um proprietary technocracy
kind of but that doesn't explain it it
does i think cover a lot of what's
happening
but uh
you know you look at what's happening
with authoritarianism rule by edict how
does
proprietary technocracy explain joe
biden saying i hereby decree because he
can reach a trillion people a million
people with once with radio he uses
technology to like that's what hitler
did too yeah but radio is 150 years old
or whatever yeah hitler did a lot right
right so that's always convincing people
with mass media it's not a proprietary
technique if he didn't have the ability
to stand up and say it
and everyone hears it on tv i don't
think that we it would have that kind of
impact
it's it's it's
technocracy is the government control of
society by technical experts yeah
so we we certainly have a
twitter ban
thing but that doesn't explain joe biden
jumping out that doesn't explain joe
biden coming out with an edict and then
everyone just adhering it was on my
twitter page when i loaded twitter for
like five days did you know that what he
did isn't it illegal yes they're saying
legal experts says
that's why i'm saying we need a new word
usurp
element of big tech corporations
wielding their power
but it's not so much the technology mass
media has been around for a long time it
is you have the private sector and the
and the public sector have merged which
some people might say is fascism but
fascism is also like traditionalist and
nationalistic so it doesn't explain what
they are they're they're it's so we need
a word that represents
global corporatism
with state you know yeah global
government corporatism a word for all of
that in one thing
do you hear me
see if anything jerkism i just typed it
in global government corporatism
corporation goes global corporatism goes
global yeah you've got private
corporations working in collusion with
the state under the under the mass under
the guise of democracy towards a a you
know global international
new world order is that what they said
is that what lori lightfoot said
i don't know that's what that australian
lady said so communism means something
fascism means something capitalism means
something and so when you're trying to
describe this i hear all these different
words thrown out and it's like it
doesn't capture the essence it's
definitely a corporatism like we were
talking about earlier with contracts if
a company has owns the rights to your
likeness and then they start building
artificial intelligence generative deep
fakes and can make you
look real and say whatever they want
forever
that's like you're a digital slave to a
corporation it's like disney owns the
rights to thor they can make chris
hemsworth's face say anything they want
on a cartoon or a tv show now do you
think it's all driven by corporations
no it's it's what's happening is there's
a a very dense powerful corporate uh
centralization of power
that is colluding with a very dense
centralization of government power
tour and and it's and and it's it's
authoritarian it's detrimental to the
working class to the people it's
exploitative it's it enslaves it is
overtly authoritarian
and so
what's the word you know i typically
would say the lucrative merger of
corporation and state would be fascism
mussolini's fascism but then you get all
sorts of arguments about the fascists
were traditionalists they were like you
know women you know at the home and
that's not what these people are these
people are ultra progressives but
they're not communists because they bel
they they work with corporations so it's
like chinese state
capitalist like it's chinese communist
capitalism it's like woke neo-liberal
corporatism but there should be just one
yeah no obviously yeah yeah i'm gonna go
naming i'm gonna say techno technocracy
final answer because without the social
media none of this could be happening
what's fascination oh that's not true
ian without the government that twitter
wouldn't have the legal protections to
make it happen
[Music]
without the government twitter could do
whatever it wanted without the democrats
coming in so when when congress comes in
and gives special protections to the
tech industry they're then able to
propaganda yeah i do i will say i think
a lot like a lot of big tech is
protected by
federal laws like i i was talking to you
about this before the show i'll talk
about this idea maybe a little bit now
about like there is an ability to like
they're a technical ability but not a
legal one to embrace and extend these
platforms where you build like a
facebook two
you log into it with your facebook
credentials and it gives you everything
in facebook one plus more and when you
comment on facebook too it backports the
facebook one for the people who are
still on there and and so on and this is
a way that we could evolve our way out
of the status quo so we wouldn't be
trapped in this equilibrium that no one
is happy with
it's laws that stop these things from
being built so the big tech companies
use laws to shut down competitors i mean
the fact that i mean you know ip is a
big one you know you're still 10 you
know apple owns rounded black corners
you know uh oracle uh
i i think they ended up losing the case
but it went on for 10 years where oracle
potentially owned the set of java apis
which made it so that you know you
couldn't be competitive with phones
there's the uh computer fraud anti-abuse
act this is a big one that a lot of
people don't know about um
it says like basically unauthorized
access to a computer is a federal crime
and what these big tech companies do is
they say well if you're scraping public
data and we tell you to stop you're now
violating the cfaa and that's a federal
crime they don't even tell you to stop
the government just literally says yeah
we decided it's a crime but this kills
pad mapper if anyone remembers that
service yeah that that was illegal it
was uh it was it was showing apartments
on a map so you could pop a map and it
would show you listings for rentals yeah
there's a there was a there was a
small companies like one guy he built
this service where if southwest
changed their flight fees it would tell
you because if you call southwest when
they lower the price of the flight
they'll give you the money back but you
have to contact them and southwest said
stop scraping our site and if you don't
we're going to call the fbi
so you can't look up i guess our public
price data you know government
mis misappropriation of government can
can stifle
innovation but no government allows
corporations to send armed men into the
other startups and and kill everyone in
the building and then make sure that no
one starts up well all right so that i
mean that's a that's a much different
debate as to like how how would how do
you know how would these competing
interests play out in terms of violence
and i'm not gonna if we want to do the
like and cap first man our kids debate
we can do it but i think that's separate
from like we can assume a monarchy or so
we can assume there's some small
government that stops the companies from
doing that but if they didn't have these
additional laws that that they were
allowed to leverage to shut down their
competitors i actually think competition
would be more i think you're right about
that big time actually
so
let's repeal the cfa build an island in
the middle east we could build islands
and live on them
i mean i i don't know i'm an optimist
like i think i think and this is why the
world is getting better despite
government getting worse entrepreneurs
always win human creativity always wins
human ingenuity the ability for humans
to be creative to come together to work
together to come up with novel solutions
like i i think it's why the world
continues to get better and i think it's
why i think we'll get out of where we
are with the big tech stuff part of
what's frustrating about it is it takes
time it takes time for the new solutions
i mean you've had minds on you're having
me on uh you know i run library and uh
which also owns odyssey and you know
these things they're getting big odyssey
grew from
nothing
to 40 million people a month in a year
you know like and it just takes time to
grow to a billion people no matter how
fast you're growing what do you think
about federating minds and library
yeah i would i'm i'm all for
interoperability uh and you know and
that's part of the beauty of all this
stuff and and when everything is open
source when everything is permissionless
we're able to innovate
so much faster and i think all of the
creative energy like you know google
google's a zombie man
like the smartest most creative people
they don't want to work at google they
don't want to work under a culture where
you have to adhere to awoke ideology and
if you don't you're going to lose your
job they don't want to sit through three
hours of diversity and inclusion
workshops a week and have to go through
all that training and have to put you
know pronouns in their signature and all
this stuff i'm not saying none of them
do but most of them don't i was thinking
last night google is it just that it's
too big
it's it's part of it's that it takes
just such a long time look i mean ibm
has been like sleepwalking for more than
a decade and it's still such a large
company
um
you know look it it doesn't usually
happen overnight where some startup
takes down the incumbent and so when
you're going through that five to ten
year reality which is how long it
actually takes for these things to play
out it feels really slow and it feels
like it's never going to happen but i
think it's happening i think it's
happening right now i think we're under
going it's like a constant a resurgence
and then it falls away and fertilizes
the soil where new things appear with
google i remember when google plus came
out and they had youtube and google plus
and it was like why didn't they just
make youtube the social network they
didn't they were trying to and then they
had this company this part of that
running google plus
youtube and they didn't know what the
other hand was doing and it was a mess
youtube was trying to turn uh google was
trying to turn youtube into google plus
and it was backfiring bad and it was
causing a lot of problems but the intent
it was happening was that youtube would
be google plus and then they were like
it's not working yeah so it makes me
think that it's too big that you can't
it's just too much authority and too
many levels of authority of things
getting passed down that it's less
effect loses f activity yeah no that's a
and that's a such an important concept
and i think it's a mistake a lot of
people make in their thinking is they
think of like oh google's like a
coherent entity like oh the ceo just
says stuff and then like things happen
it's like you know when you and true of
government sometimes large corporations
well no but it's a bunch of individual
agents all with their own like local
incentives and a lot of times inside of
the large thing they're competing
interests they're competing branches of
government that are at odds with one
another they're competing factions of
google that are allowed with one another
there's not an ability for one person to
just issue some top-down order and then
everything happens and and the most
creativity the best stuff happens when
you have people with that bottom-up
incentive where they believe in the
mission and they want to do the right
thing like very few
jobs especially creative work can be
like purely quantified where it's like
you oh produce your 40 widgets of stuff
and we're going to win because we're
producing 40 widgets of creativity per
week and we're you know highly it's not
the way it works it's not the way uh
true creation happens
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to the channel share the show with your
friends go to timcast.com we have a
members only segment coming up later on
11 or so p.m let's read what y'all have
to say
dragon's pride says all disrespect
intended if libertarians would have
voted for trump we wouldn't be in this
mess
the problem with that is the assumption
that libertarians shall share the values
of trump supporters and i think as we
can see with new hampshire a lot of
libertarians don't yeah i mean look what
trump grew the federal budget okay trump
you know trump had followed his impulses
he might have been better on covet than
he was but he didn't trump said he was
going to end the wars but he didn't and
i'd say all this as someone who thinks
trump has would have been better than
biden right there's one of my choices up
but like
you know trump was not a particularly
libertarian president and trump would
have continued to grow government and so
on and so like would it have happened
more slowly maybe but but this is these
are two terrible choices here no matter
what if you're a libertarian
all right michael fernando melo says
nice free state new hampshire is on my
short list best city tc is for damastan
going to be in maryland or west virginia
sounds tempting only one is
constitutional carry though it's going
to be in west virginia of course there's
a lot of land in west virginia like
hundreds of acres it's relatively cheap
and apparently there are investors who
are interested in a freedom community
and wealthy ones but i don't know if
that's for me um there are some other
people i know who might want to run
something like that we want to do mostly
more like a hacker acreage a hacker farm
where people can we you know build
blimps and stuff um oh yeah and we we're
we're moving on the zeppelin project
right yeah
big announcement um so there's a story
i'll just tell you real quick for a long
time for some reason wikipedia claimed i
invented some kind of live streaming
zeppelin i don't know why they claim
this it has something to do with some
article where i think a friend of mine
made a passive comment and then a
journalist you know someone said
something like it'd be really cool if we
had like a zeppelin that could just
be resting on your roof and then like
just go up and anywhere in the world you
could dial in and just have access to
this live streaming aerial camera
and then someone claimed i did it and
then wikipedia put it in and it said tim
poole invented the the zeppelin stream
or something and then i was like this
isn't true and they wouldn't remove it
finally they removed it
and as a point of spite i said now i'm
actually going to invent it
and so it's under it's under
construction it's going to be here and
we're going to film it and then the
funny thing is this work it's confusing
the original article
will retroactively become true
so what what happens can wikipedia put
that article in
because what it's saying is true even
though it's missing the context of it
wasn't true when it was written
yeah isn't that amazing
how does that work
like if there was an article that said
ian has long hair and they put it in but
then ian didn't have long hair he had
short hair
and then people like this is fake news
get rid of it and then ian grew his hair
out and they're like now it's true put
it back i'm like but that's the don't
that article is not true you need to
write a new one isn't that what it says
it'll make it and then you know what
we're thinking of doing
we're thinking of naming the zeppelin
something like
in um
well we're gonna name it like in 2012
no
we'll name the the hangar in 2012. so in
2012 no yeah yeah yeah
we'll name we'll name the hanger 2012 or
whatever in 2012.
in or 2012 no 2012 tim built it'll be
it'll be called uh
yeah in 2012 so it'll say tim poole
built the zeppelin in a hangar
in 2012. no no in the hangar we just
called 2012. welcome to 2012 and like in
2012 tim built that zeppelin no there's
like a hangar called
yeah if you guys have ideas man
send
naming it something so that when they
write in the article it would confuse
people and they wouldn't know when it
was made yeah i think i think this is
perfect yeah the zeppelin's gonna be
maniac it's gonna be an awesome man
wikipedia has gone so downhill though
but i'm really just interested how
they'll respond to this because it's
like a really interesting bind for the
editors to be in
like we've officially it's it exists
that we've we've been working with some
people we've we've got it uh i think
it's mostly done yeah and so we're gonna
unveil it but it's happened so now i
will say this definitively that article
that claimed i did invent the zeppelin
is now correct well what technically we
didn't invent it we're using technology
what does that mean exactly we pieced we
had this one pieced together for us i
don't know i'm gonna go with the article
still false because it wasn't true when
it was written exactly yeah that means
it's false but if someone set read it to
you without the date it would be a true
statement
yeah but i don't think that's how the
truth works i i agree with you okay i'm
just curious how wikipedia is oh yeah
yeah but also ian you underestimate what
inventions maybe i do you really do so
like you know when when an alarm clock
is invented they're like we have
speakers and we have these things and
like oh i know i can make i can buy the
timer from jim so that when the timer
stops it rings oh yeah we'll be modding
it out we'll be modding the heck out of
that thing that's what it is it's
standing on the shoulders of giants so
certainly you know uh a lot of this is
really understanding about phones too
and like all modern tech it's basically
a company shops around saying can you
build something like this and they'll be
like we'll make it and they put the
pieces together and say look what we've
created you know it's a new a new
invention or something so
you know let's read some more let's see
what we got
all right let's see
nightingale mori says what's the safe
and ready meals promo uh what is it
safeandreadymeals.com yeah
i am not doing a promo for them because
that would be a specific thing but um we
sometimes do promote
uh safeandreadymeals.com uh i don't know
how that works because like normally
when you read the promo you have to like
tell youtube but if someone asks us and
we just tell them what it is like what
if i ask you
that might be a promo
i want to ask you about what's in your
water bottle over there the eternal reds
we're not we're not doing delicious by
the way yeah we i i you know we shouted
them out yesterday it's like i legit
drink this stuff yeah it's amazing it's
so good yeah let's put in the water and
get that vitamin c timothy peterson says
never laughed as hard watching shim cast
as i did last night
ian mid tangent said what were we
talking about i was honest this is an
enigma that was during the members we
were talking about our souls being
devoured by cthulhu and i was thinking
of the magnetic fields going to bigger
magnetic fields i'm like one of the
biggest
all of a sudden
all of a sudden mid-sentence he looks at
jack and goes i forgot what i'm talking
about we're like what are we talking
about i was looking at his eyes you know
one of those
connections
distracting
yeah
all right let's see
adam spalding says nh native here 100
support the free state project
yeah that's right adam hope to see you
at some free state meetups
bog denoff says tim just 200k pool
well um how about i can help give some
uh some lessons to those who aren't
familiar with the market um 200 000 for
a property is actually really really
cheap because you don't walk in with a
check for 200 000
you need and often maybe only five
percent of that and then you walk in
which could still be a lot mind you but
you go to a bank and you said like a
loan for property that's how you get a
mortgage on property so if you're
looking at 100 acres
and it's
what is that 2 000 per acre
ridiculously cheap you look in like uh
western west virginia
and it's like 30 acres for a million
dollars
so yeah that that is really really cheap
if you live in the suburbs or like the
south side of chicago the houses there
are a couple hundred grand 180 to 200.
you go to a bank sometimes you can do no
money down and you get a loan to buy it
so yeah 200k is cheap
well relative yep preston thames says
student pilot here something that i have
found so astonishing about the green new
deal is that it views turbines jet
engines as dirty when turbines are
easily twice as efficient as other ice
for aircraft interesting
i don't know
wait i don't you're saying that the
authors of the green new deal got
something scientifically incorrect that
doesn't sound yeah that doesn't sound
like that
it was interesting goldilocks production
says youtube isn't liking the stream's
topic right now lots of stream freezes
means tim's talking about the right
topics keep it up guys it's probably you
yeah yeah
i really doubt youtube likes you i they
do not yeah we we have had uh our
odyssey app has been in review at
youtube for seven weeks
and uh i have uh some some inside uh i
don't want to say too much i know i have
good information that uh it has been
sort of flagged to the highest level
from i know about your experience with
library my experience at mines is
whenever there's like technical glitches
very very very 98.9 percent of the time
it's it's like a back end glitch and
people think they're being censored and
they're like freaking out and i'm like
dude this yeah man we rolled out a new
update yeah i mean especially i mean
look some some people are sort of a more
conspiratorially minded and so
everything is a conspiracy yes
all right i don't know how to read
cyrillic so i'll just say it like it's
not tabby says or taboo oh okay that's
taboo last night's members show with
jack got pretty heated hope you guys
were cool after the fact now this is the
part where i say first time super chat
oh yeah but the two weeks before was
even more he did on the show he debated
like a half hour went viral so oh yeah
dude if if
if you can't you know there's no
principle to stand by or you're not
staying by your principles if you're not
going to get into an actual argument
with people that you know and trust and
be willing to like recognize you
disagree on very core issues that's
literally like the purpose of what we do
here for the most part is yeah i
disagree with charlie kirk when he came
and i'm like wow i really don't agree
with him on this or that issue but yeah
that's just the way it is what are you
what are you gonna do are you gonna get
all mad i think mature responsible
adults recognize they're like man i
really disagree with jack on those
points cool dude great guy we're looking
forward to having him back in a couple
weeks he comes back this makes me feel
like we haven't disagreed enough
yeah this is just the beginning yeah
yeah i think i think my strongest moral
foundation is probably liberty you know
so when it comes to like
a lot of issues
on government stuff i'm like man we can
make a lot of good arguments on that one
and then when it comes to should the
government have the authority and i'm
usually like no probably not because
they screw things up and kill people you
know so yeah
yeah i i do think the great the the the
crossover we needed most was the black
lives matter anti-mandate you know
protests yeah which of course we'll get
zero coverage
it'll get co-opted
harvey slayer says i don't think
secession is the answer necessarily a
seceded state can become more tyrannical
than it was before take california for
instance these problems will persist
unless people oversee gov operation more
always hold their feet to the fire yeah
but i've been thinking about this
why should i care how californians live
it's not tyranny unless you don't like
it that's true this is you know i i've
gotten heat for saying this but i think
libertarians are the most depressed
minority i think the most oppressed
minority in the country because it's not
a pr if you support what the government
does it's not oppressing if i want to be
whipped i'm not i'm not being oppressed
right yeah so if you look at how much is
any group of people dominated how much
does the government dominate a group of
people how how much is is the it
absolutely taking away
their right to live the way that they
want to libertarians are more oppressed
than any minority 100 percent i agree
although i have heard the phrase
benevolent tyrant like sometimes people
can dictate through tyranny but do
really good stuff with it no there was a
guy in ancient athens that did that
into the greatest trade colony in the
world sure and hugo chavez you know top
people this guy legit walked into this
nothing backwoods athens and turned it
into a global
and the communist party of china lifted
hey george washington had to act as a
tyrant for a short period of time that
he gave up the power yeah but that's so
i don't i don't believe there's there's
there's a benevolent dictatorship that's
look at benevolent tyrant i mean there's
i understand the concept i'm saying i do
not agree
with the idea that you can be a
benevolent tyrant do you think you can
dictate by decree and do good things
with it
uh i think you can do good things that
doesn't make you benevolent it makes you
a tyrant is there a local restaurant
here that you like
yeah i guess all right do you think
they're benevolent to you
define what you mean by do you view them
as benevolently i'm not trying to this
isn't like a trap i think this there's
no like right answer this question but
what do you mean by benevolent in this
context well like
in in the same way that benevolent would
mean are they kind to you are they being
good to you
the the restaurant yeah
i honestly
would say
indeterminate
okay look when you sit down and they're
like hi thanks for coming here's your
menu and then say i'll have the chicken
wings and say okay and then come back
and give me the chicken wings it's not
really an interaction there yeah they
might not be my phone because like most
restaurants are dictatorships most
companies are dictatorships and they're
oh yeah they're serving you all
corporations are basically authoritarian
yeah
they're there there are laws stopping
companies from doing certain things
but uh
they're they're they're not necessarily
dictatorships i mean there's a trade
agreement there there's a mutual
understanding they're not going to spit
in your food and you're not going to
throw it on the floor no sure but i mean
like there's they're typically owned by
a single person or a family they have
complete authority if they want to kick
someone off the property they can do
that if they want to fire someone they
can do that they can change the menu the
next day they can make whatever they
want they can change they set all the
prices they decide everything about the
way yeah but you're you're you're
comparing like a government to a
building
this this defines tyrant as an absolute
ruler unrestrained by law or
constitution so it doesn't say anything
about good or evil it's just the issue
absolutely ruling authority the reason
why i say you can't be a benevolent
tyrant is that there will always be
people who say i disagree and if the
tyrant says i'm not constrained and can
do whatever i want he will be crushing
and oppressing those people who disagree
even if they disagree for stupid reasons
you can have an individual who is
genuinely the smartest most uh the
kindest person who says i know to solve
all the world's problems
and if someone says i demand my voice be
heard and he says no you're wrong shut
up tyrant not benevolent
well what if there's like a hundred
people and one guy says i'm in charge
and i need to get us across the river
because the wildfire is coming and one
guy goes no we need to stay here then he
can stay and the tyrant says
no we're going and takes everyone so he
saved everyone's life
they would consider him a saint they
would love him and praise him for saving
their lives what what are your thoughts
on that yeah uh it reminds me of the
like drunk driving hypothetical so i can
say what i'll do right it's like the
scenario is like you know your friend is
extremely no no no i just i'm curious
direct answer to what he asked is it
there's there's a hundred people on a
shoreline on you know in front of a
river with a wildfire approaching one
man says we do not cross he takes him by
force across the river or he leaves the
other 99 and leaves the guy whatever i
mean well certainly i don't i see no
reason with taking the 99 and leaving
the guy i to be honest i don't really
have a have a problem with also forcing
the guy
like in terms of what i do it like i
think i don't really think there are
very many absolute moral rules i think
they all break down i think
i think forcing the person is is
authoritarianism sure but it might be
good it could still be good
but who are you to decide for someone
else when they make a decision yeah i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna go to the mat on
this one like i'm fine with leaving them
the force of a large crowd on a person
who says you know what's funny is the
problem with that circumstance is that
it turns out that the reason the one guy
says don't cross was because the river
was full of piranhas okay and then he
forces him in the river and he gets
killed so he'll die here's one you might
agree with if you don't like that one uh
your friend is extremely drunk all right
and he says that yeah i'm gonna get in
my car and i'm gonna drive home drunk is
very different well but in other words
you decide to you decide to wrestle him
to the ground and take his keys and
throw him into the woods so he can't
drive him you've got a man you violate
his property rights and you acted you
died i disagree that's that's absolutely
not the same thing a guy's bleeding on
the ground and you're like if i don't
put pressure on the wound you'll die
don't you dare touch me i'm putting the
pressure on i'm not saying these are
exactly the same scenario well if you
put wait if you put so that's it so all
right the drunk driving one the idea is
that the behavior is creating some
externalities uh so maybe it's different
but if you put pressure on the wound
when the guy says no how's that
different than carrying him across the
bridge you don't know what's in the
river you don't know why he's objecting
and so you also do have to consider that
when someone's so there's there's
extreme circumstances where we act in
our best in our best of our abilities to
like legitimately save a life when it's
obvious
you know like
if you are coming across a very complex
situation and one man says i hereby
decree and you say no that's wrong and
he says shut up and use the force of the
mob to shut you down often you could end
up walking into a river full of piranhas
and then you all die maybe the guy
bleeding to death wants to die because
he's about to wanting to die is
different from saying i object on this
but you might the tyrant may may know
that there's danger whereas the person
is objecting doesn't know
it's it's it's still complex social
situations we cannot create a
circumstance in which a tyrant can just
say i'm smarter than you therefore you
must no but if they have knowledge that
you don't have and and there's a
dissension okay
let's play the game 99 people come to
the river and the one benevolent tyrant
says i know the river is safe he's wrong
let's force him across and then the next
time they come across the river the
[ __ ] says i'm in charge and then throws
everybody off a cliff and they and the
guy's like don't throw me off the cliff
please and they're like you do as you're
told and then do it so history would
write the first guy as a benevolent
tyrant the second guy would be in the
point the point is this is why we don't
allow absolute power because that's why
we prevent against it yeah because it
can go haywire because sideways will go
ahead and not always will no there are
definitely instances throughout history
of tyranny being very good
it's the exception not the rule i agree
with you create a circumstance where
someone can oppress people because they
think they're smarter and that is what
you will get now if there's an emergency
and someone's lying on the ground and
they're bleeding and they're like don't
touch me don't touch me that happens all
the time
and it's like bro this is a very
different circumstance where we legit
know you're bleeding or a drunk driver
where they're not within their right
frame of mind i don't i don't think you
would get the outcome of of um sort of
like evil behavior if there's
competition between tyrants
well yes tyron has absolute power for
his competition they're not a tyrant
okay well he's talking about a tyranny i
suppose they're still tyrants of a city
state i mean there's competition in the
case of city-states
i think you know this is a very specific
example but for the most part
there's there's always going to be
someone who either doesn't understand
who understands better or quite frankly
just refuses to comply
and the idea that a tyrant is going to
go to someone who says i refuse to
comply and says we're going to force you
that is not benevolence it is just
someone who has convinced the people he
is better for some reason well but
sometimes the ignorant person really is
making him a bad decision and the tyrant
has to correct for that you know the
issue is that
it's like the quote i mentioned before
the idea that some people are just
stupid so they need smarter people to
lead them but they're the they're
basically the same there's an average
are there smarter people sure look at
all of our leaders man imagine if joe
biden got dictatorial power and could
just demand by edict people be forced to
get vaccinated
so there's and you have all the
democrats saying what a good leader and
they're cheering for him saying that's a
benevolent dictator a benevolent tyrant
and i'm saying it doesn't matter whether
you think you're right or wrong this
should not be allowed because you are
not always right and often could be
wrong and we need a balance of power we
need to decentralize centralized
authority in my opinion is almost always
bad i'm not big on absolutes because
sometimes george washington needs to say
we have to do this because we're in a
war and there are emergencies sometimes
abraham lincoln says i'm going to do
some things that are really awful that
we think are still bad to this day but
we're like man with slavery just really
bad so we're kind of we kind of accept
that he did bad things we still will say
it was tyrannical
let's read some more super chats because
we uh
gotta read more
mark neal says what's the free state
view on immigration asking as a canadian
who wants to escape and be free
if you are liberty minded we want you uh
in new hampshire regardless where you
come from um it's we obviously don't
control federal immigration laws but
also we're not darks so uh do do what
you gonna do i know i know some people
who have um
what's it called when you get married to
uh get into a country there's like some
term for that anyway uh you know come
and come and meet a partner come uh you
know so if you're having trouble getting
citizenship come from vacation come meet
some nice nice new hampshire woman or a
nice new hampshire man best and your
brightest yeah
the
tj drummer says oregonian here sick of
the pacific northwest and democrat
control wife and i are looking at west
virginia and new hampshire and would
gladly join the liberty movement you see
it's tough i tell people to go to west
virginia because you know we're we're
expanding here we're bringing people
down we've moved quite a few people out
here
but we don't have this grand mission of
anything
like the free state project although
maybe i would say maybe we should but i
don't want to take away from the cancer
you know what i mean it'd be amazing if
there were two of us though like they
can't chop the heads off of all the
gophers if they all stand but it would
also it would also split the power yeah
if people really want a free state
project new hampshire is the way to go
west virginia's got its freedoms and
we're happy there
maybe we'll we'll set something up in
new hampshire for the future yeah i
don't think it's something you can
really dilute look what i'd say number
one thing is come for a visit come check
it out like don't don't window shop the
rest of your life like comment come
inside try it on see how you like it uh
and that's what you should really think
of mentally as the next step you know
it's it look some people go all the way
to seoul and that's awesome and so if
you're ready to move tomorrow get on the
plane we're happy to welcome you but i
think that like the number one thing is
is to come up for that visit come check
it out and get plugged in and meet the
people here we'll connect if you have a
family we'll connect you with similar
families whatever your interests are
we'll connect you with people similar so
if someone was going to do that would
they get like an airbnb somewhere what
would you advise like where would they
go to stay
so we have a fsp.org visit has a form
you fill it out a human being a real
live real one not an ai not a chatbot a
member of the fsp staff typically a
woman named chris lopez will reach out
to you she's awesome shout out to chris
she'll uh
she'll contact you
and she'll talk to you she'll help you
plan a trip she'll learn about you and
that kind of thing
you know easy times to come our liberty
forum which is the first weekend in
march nhlibertyforum.com pork fest the
end of june uh porkfest.com uh but you
can come out for a trip any time there's
events non-stop there's a calendar at
fsp.org calendar it's like there are
like four liberty events a day
throughout the state so there's always
stuff going on regardless of when you
come but is there like a fredamastand
has like what i mean has someone set up
a large acreage where you can just come
and it's you know
um
yeah there's uh there's a place called
like croydon farms uh which like
definitely some some vibes to this place
where like people come in and out of
there um they have a farm they have a
bunch of animals um they have like
regular potluck dinners and and stuff
like this and that's definitely a lot of
people um especially people interested
in sort of like farming and like more
rural off the grid type living a lot of
people enter the community uh that way
but people who want to do it more like
urban lane like i i run an airbnb i have
uh
three different uh rooms for
libertarians people are coming and i do
it off airbnb too but people come in all
the time and just come in for a visit
and those are i i talk to people who are
more interested in like entrepreneurship
and blockchain i'm not a i'm not a
farmer but i think it's you know so
there's all kinds of people and so
that's part of why like i don't know you
but if you contact the organization
we'll learn about you and we'll help you
figure out like what makes sense for you
what we're doing with our for damastan
is it's going to be i mean it's almost
50 acres so we can set up a shooting
range we're going to have like a biking
area we're going to be very very strict
with our with our range it's not going
to be a very open the public kind of
thing but we are going to have it's
going to be a private space
mostly invite only
only public in the sense that members of
teamcast.com might you know gain access
in certain circumstances when we do
events we're into events and then we'll
sell limited you know tickets we could
probably accommodate like several
hundred people but we're going to have a
big facility with you know skateboarding
biking scooters blades all that stuff
we're gonna have music we're gonna have
a big stage we're gonna have dirt jumps
um we have a pond we're gonna we're
gonna set up all this just cool freedom
stuff and the facility is gonna be like
a hacker space that's great so we're
gonna be making drones and blimps we're
gonna build like gliders i'll make a a a
flight suit and jump off the building
with it or something just having fun
experimenting having a good time and
playing music playing video games it's
going to be it's going to be a whole
it's going to be amazing that sounds
sweet and i think this is the future
like getting together with like
like-minded people i think it's just
like it's a much better way to live i'm
so happy raising my kids in new
hampshire like compared to what it would
have been like if i was still in
philadelphia oh yeah someone said free
kakistan
i'll buy a big piece of land and we'll
give it to some some memers some
yeah you might need an embassy maybe
maybe you need an embassy
isn't there like there's like some small
plot of land in nevada that declared
independence and the federal government
just was like
yeah get out of here that's actually
what makes the federal you know if you
don't like it leave is a valid principle
like if there's actually this
competition for government the
governments don't follow their own rules
you know we saw it with um with the
liberland we saw it with sealand if
people know the story of sealand where
they
knocked this island off but violated all
the rules and they do it you know so
when people try to start something new
the governments get together and they
shut it down and there is effectively
yeah it's awesome you want to know why
government's so bad imagine if we went
back in time to like 1900 and we said
all the restaurants in existence that's
it there's no one's allowed to ever
start a new restaurant the existing
chains can continue to operate but
that's it there will never be a new one
like would restaurants be good today
they would suck
and that's what happened with government
you know the beauty of america is there
was this new thing it was an experiment
it was people putting their own skin in
the game to come and try a different way
of living and not and it was better than
everything that came before
and it was so good
that europe copied it
that other people copied what happened
in america and that's what we want to
happen again is people getting together
putting their skin in the game saying
let's try a new and better way to live
and then if it works people will copy us
we got we'll do one more garhent says
please have ian do the political compass
he's the millennial authoritarian who
says they aren't he doesn't like the new
hampshire he doesn't like new hampshire
seceding and now he wants a computer
program to rule a state it's long-haired
stalin plus herbs you misrepresented i
don't want it to rule the state i wanted
to advise the governor um also i think
secession is dangerous so i'm wargaming
the the potentialities of mismanaging
something like that i don't i'm not
against like creating new states of
union
though all right let's see we'll we'll
do one more we'll do two more
stephen d parker jr says tim i'm a
teacher not far from you our vax man it
goes in november 1st one creepy rule is
that unvax must register with the county
health department
oh wow
william barger
i am a new hampshire native mises caucus
guy lp member tim cass listener for
years new hampshire is the best you'll
be blown away when you see how many
libertarians are here and really plug
into the community come visit and and
see let's go
let's go i think what to set up our like
new hampshire campus and start
experiencing as well yeah totally when
they're on the possibility you want to
do uh can you do road trips to pork fest
or something like that come on
where exactly is pork fest held it's
about two hours north of manchester so
if we can get land near that area so we
can set up a production facility we can
actually just schedule the show for a
new hampshire site and then go there
there's a space that we could give you
to use as a as a studio for when you're
we'd have to build something and have
something static totally okay people
working there maintaining the property
making the equipment make sure it's safe
and all the stuff gotcha well the space
is set up for that's at a campsite where
it's like so like basically you can
actually literally
buy that's the trickiest part um well
they've got starlink in upstate new york
now yeah so that that's active and you
know maybe have to test that out it's
it's fast enough but uh we'll see my
friends if you haven't already smash the
like button go to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna have a member segment
coming up around 11 or so p.m plus we
have a huge library
you really got to check out the last
members only we do with alex jones it
was an hour and a half it was a long
conversation it was a whole lot of fun
the man is out of control he is he is a
a powerful entity who will speak and
there's nothing anyone can do to stop
him yep but it was right it was really
fascinating you can follow me at tim
cast you can follow the show at tim cast
irl again smash the like button you want
to shout anything out before we get
before well they should also follow you
on odyssey uh and follow follow timon
odyssey uh if you uh so follow the first
day project we're on every social media
like literally every single one so if
you're on youtube follow us on youtube
if you're on twitter follow us on
twitter freestatenh facebook um we're on
every platform so follow the free state
project if you liked what i had to say
uh i'm on odyssey as well at kufffj i'm
also on twitter at my full name jeremy
kaufman so if you want to hear more from
me there i've got a lot of a lot of [ __ ]
posts so be careful uh and then uh and
what i'd really say is like if you're if
you're frustrated with big tech you
don't like any of that stuff create an
odyssey account and and check that out
as well you'll learn some cryptocurrency
for watching videos uh and you can enjoy
tim's show in there as well yeah i think
you can port your youtube account into
odyssey yeah seamlessly if you're a
youtube creator it is i it's one of
those things where i actually lie to
people and say it's harder than it is
because if i tell them it's as easy as
it actually is they won't believe you
like i'm like it takes under a minute
they're like that's not true so i
started telling people i'm like it takes
like five minutes because that's more
believable
uh but it's uh uh but it's very very
easy you click one button it brings over
your entire channel wow it's incredible
mines does that too on ongoing not just
the past it will bring over your future
content awesome thanks for coming man
great this was awesome in crossland
peace out
and you guys i hope you enjoyed
tonight's conversation i'm going to have
to visit new jersey you guys are welcome
to follow me on twitter at sour patch
lids i'm about to roll over 100 000
followers i'm excited about that i don't
know what it means but i'm stoked come
join me over there it's a good time i'm
pretty sure we're going to be in the new
studio on monday yes so that's big the
table is bigger and we'll have some
surprises for everybody come monday in
the new studio tomorrow's me a lot of
fun shane cashman will be here because
we're launching the new show which i
suppose will save the name for tomorrow
but go to timcast.com
check out the members only segment we'll
see y'all there
you